this episode is brought to you by kettle
and fire do love me my kettle and fire i
believe i first heard about kettle and
fire when it was originally recommended
to me by
one of your favorites fan favorite
podcast guest and ketogenesis expert
among many other things dr dominic de
agostino so what is kettle on fire
kettle and fire offers premium bone
broth made with bones from 100 grass-fed
and grass-finished cows and organic
free-range chickens they can buy bones
with organic herbs and vegetables and
filtered water and steel kettles
then the mixture is slow simmered for 14
plus hours at 130 degrees fahrenheit to
ensure that as many nutrients collagen
and amino acids as possible are able to
soak into the broth and all that
goodness is fantastic for supporting
your gut health immune system weight
loss your fasting regimen whatever it
might be and they make it extremely
convenient just heat and eat five
minutes on the stovetop or one minute in
the microwave it's great as a snack you
can also sip it straight out of a mug or
honestly sometimes i just sip it right
out of the box you can also add it as a
flavor to recipes and they sent me some
eye popping stats it's pretty amazing 24
million plus cartons sold 25 000 plus
five star reviews on amazon and their
own website two-year shelf life and zero
preservatives added flavors antibiotics
hormones or colorings and all of their
broths are paleo keto friendly and
whole30 approved they're also my
neighbors here in austin texas and i'm
happy to support a local company so
check them out you can save 25 off of
your order by going to kettleandfire.com
tim that's spelled out k-e-t-t-l-e
a-n-d-f-i-r-e dot com tim and using code
tim at checkout one more time that's
kettleandfire.com
tim and code tim at checkout
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which i've been using
since 2017. i have two of them upstairs
from where i'm sitting at this moment
and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so i'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all form furniture i've
got two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional couch and i'll come
back to that you can pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs the sofa size the shape to make
sure it's perfect for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular and easy these things fit
together kind of like lego pieces
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone you can
also start small and kind of build on
top of it if you want to get a smaller
couch and then build out on it which is
actually in a way what i did because i
can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman in a matter of about 60 seconds
it's pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural leg finish which is
their lightest color and i dig it i mean
i've been using these things hours and
hours and hours every single day so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever so check it out take a
look they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have imagined and i'm very
very happy so to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout that's allforum.com
tim and use code tim at checkout
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living
[Music]
just a quick note stay around until the
end of the episode in fact listen past
the end of the interview to hear
alyssa's word for word scripts she's put
together just for you and this episode
that was a follow-up after our entire
conversation they're not in her book not
on the website first she offers you a
set of scripts that lead up to firing
someone next a script to help you get
feedback in your job so you can increase
the likelihood of getting promoted
then a few scripts to foster great
one-on-one conversations of different
types including career coaching with
your employees and many more so keep
listening after we end the interview
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today we're going to skip the
preamble is alyssa cohn c-o-h and you
can find her on twitter at alyssa cohn
she's been coaching entrepreneurs for
nearly 20 years including many people i
know including yours truly we've done
quite a bit of work together she is
advised founders and executives at venmo
etsy draftkings wirecutter mac weldon
invision and tory burch among others she
has also coached ceos and c-suite
executives at enterprises such as dell
hitachi sony google microsoft bloomberg
the new york times company calvin klein
and on and on and on she's the author of
brand new book from startup to grown-up
a guidebook for entrepreneurs on the
leadership journey from founder to ceo
her articles have appeared in harvard
business review forbes and ink magazines
and she's been featured as an expert on
bloomberg tv the bbc world news and in
the new york times a recovering cpa
we're going to talk about that and one
time startup cfo and strategy consultant
she is now in addition to being a coach
an angel investor and advisory board
member outside of work she is a very
amateur rap artist and
i was privileged enough to think view
one of the first recordings of said rap
and an investor in broadway shows two of
which have won tony awards you can find
her everywhere online on all of the
social media platforms just about at
alyssa cohen that's twitter instagram
linkedin facebook and of course at her
website alyssa cohen a-l-i-s-a-c-o-h-n
dot com alyssa nice to see you again and
nice to hear you again
great to see you tim and thanks so much
for having me today it's really great to
see you
i am excited to dig in we are going to
as per usual run out of time before we
run out of material but i thought we
would start somewhere
we have not spent much time previously
this is usually me asking you questions
and for help on various
issues weaknesses of mind challenges
whatever it might be
i thought we would begin with
the background some of your story
because honestly i'm embarrassed to say
that i don't know more of it
so could you just paint a picture for us
of where you grew up and then the sort
of professional journey that led you to
coaching because i know that's not where
you started i grew up in a small town
holliston massachusetts which is right
next to hopkinton which is where the
boston marathon starts so that's kind of
by definition 26.2 miles southwest of
boston and i barely left holliston until
i went to my undergrad college boston
university and i was journalism major
and i worked in the nonprofit world for
a little while so i was the chief of
staff to the provost at northeastern
university and we were doing strategic
planning
and the provost at some point said you
can't manage faculty because they have
tenure and even then i was super young
and i thought
what do you mean like how can it be that
people will only do what you want them
to do in like service of the
organization because otherwise you'll
fire them so
i thought a lot about that and i wanted
to go explore that so i did a little
stint in strategy consulting at monitor
and then i went to business school and i
went to cornell and at cornell i got all
turned around and i was no longer
focused on people in organizations i was
focused on finance and accounting of all
things and also strategy so i exited
business school into pwc
into the so-called advanced development
program it's five years to partner so
fast track to partner and i thought hey
this is great
and as i got into my life i will say
that i told one of my professors i said
i'm going to pwc and he said well that
will be very refreshing for the
profession and i didn't quite know what
he meant but as i went through i just
realized this is not necessarily my
tribe and also pwc
was so big that i just felt like oh i
can't really make a difference here it
was a fantastic firm and a fantastic
actually experience but after two and a
half years i had sort of i'm happy to
tell you about it i had like a dramatic
moment that i realized this is not for
me
and so i went off to try to figure out
what's for me what do i want to do
and i met a coach at that point and
that's when i realized oh that's what i
want to do
well let's
let's talk about two things real quick
to interject so the first with the
provost and the comment that you can't
manage
faculty because they have tenure or if
they have tenure
that was
meant to convey that if we don't have
the looming shadow of possible
punishment by firing you can't get
people to do what you want them to do
was that the the sort of gist of it
it's what he meant yeah and then
the dramatic moment rather than gloss
over that let's go right into it because
a lot of people
stick around in sort of this walking
dead
sentiment in some profession or job they
don't like for a very very long time so
what happened i guess at that time it
would have been at pwc yeah
what was the the catalyst
i was a pwc and again it is a great firm
and also for me i just felt like this is
not feeding my soul and this is a big
four big five accounting firm for people
who don't know yeah
and i woke up one morning and i just
thought to myself spontaneously i hope i
get the flu so i don't have to go into
work tomorrow
and you know life goes on and life goes
on and to be honest with you 18 hours
later i was being rushed to the
emergency room by my boyfriend at the
time with the flu and i showed up at the
emergency room and i was in boston and
you know they took one look at me and
they wheeled me into this room and they
pumped me up with saline i mean i had a
really bad flu
and
i just thought at that time that night
as i spent the night there and for the
days that followed i just thought i
can't do this anymore it's not me i
can't do it i thought like i'd rather be
a waitress i can't handle
this experience of not feeling sort of
nourished and satisfied
i guess for me
that moment of realizing i'd actually
rather have the flu like i'd rather get
sick so i don't have to go into work was
almost like scary it was like oh my
body's trying to tell me something and i
was wondering how often have i not
listened to my body as i've sort of head
down forced march like you can do it
because i was very goal-oriented and
this is one of the first times in my
life i just went off my plan and thought
what am i gonna do now so i was down for
the count for like two weeks and every
time i thought about going back to work
my fever went back up and you know i
thought oh but what am i going to do now
like washed up at 27 what am i going to
do now
but in my head i kept thinking these
words kept coming through my mind to
make a difference to make a difference
that the work of my hands
matters in the world and that's what i
set out to try to figure out how can i
do something that was going to help me
make a difference
and
what happened what did you do because i
would imagine a lot of people have that
desire but then they're
groping around in the dark or yeah they
never quite arrive at an answer so how
did you arrive and answer
first of all i went through a number of
dead ends i interviewed with goldman i
interviewed
i was looking for
what is the thing that is going to make
me happy i looked into financial
planning i can help people buy a house
or go to college so i went down a number
of dead ends and then i went to this
conference and i was a volunteer at this
conference it was not really like me
it's called the body and soul conference
and okay hold on hold on pause pause
real quick so
so this is just my nature with these
conversations
because i think the internal process is
really important here or lack thereof so
pwc huge firm yeah you're like i would
rather be a waitress
why then
interview
or consider goldman sachs what led you
to consider goldman
i went to
an ivy league school i invested all this
time and energy into the mba
all my peers
were like on wall street or doing some
sort of corporate finance job inside of
a company
there wasn't a lot of context for
getting off track
and so i didn't know at the time i
didn't have a lot of ideas like what are
you gonna do i i really didn't know what
i was gonna do
when you have a kind of a pedigree
you have a lot of
pressure i guess i would say
to
focus your efforts that only a set of
things are good enough only a set of
things are the right things
and it's not so easy to go off path
yeah i think also i mean if your
experience mirrors
mine at all early on there's also a very
limited or at least i had and i think a
lot of my classmates had very limited
awareness of options outside of a few
things i mean very few things right like
investment banking management consulting
big five accounting that's expanded a
little bit but at the time
really
law perhaps if you continue with the
professional degree but the
the types of companies that were
recruiting and the types of stories you
heard tended to be at least in my case
from
really a tiny tiny tiny slice of the
total spectrum of possibilities
definitely a tiny slice and again there
was like a sense of
you could only do things which were sort
of in some way worthy of all that time
and energy spent in your education and
again building kind of this pedigree and
so there's a lot of to your point you
didn't always know what was out there
but also if you strayed from this tight
narrow list of things you could possibly
do it felt like somehow you were not
being successful you were giving up you
were not fulfilling the promise that you
had thought about in business school
that's how it felt
why did goldman not happen
there was three things that happened at
once i interviewed with a number of
folks i again i interviewed financial
planning firms and
i got this interview at goldman and i
did that interview and in the meantime
i have gone to this conference this body
and console conference as a volunteer
and they said
cheryl richardson is now gonna we did
this orientation and then okay cheryl
richardson's now gonna speak to the
volunteers and i'm like okay who is that
and body and soul conference just to
reiterate not
what i would envision
the immediate
native habitat to be for you
all due respect
right this is more of a cultural comment
than a judgment of any type
so you ended up there because your
boyfriend at the time was like you're
striking out so you might as well come
here or
twisted your arm behind your back or
thought it'd be helpful he was a yogi
type my boyfriend at the time and so he
did me the favor of kind of dragging me
like we should go to this you know yoga
e conference and i'm thinking oh this is
not my thing but i was
you know tim
you get the flu
i realized for me something's got to
change
so at that moment i was more open to
something like yeah i'm a little i think
i'm more touchy-feely or whatever you
want to call it now i'm going to be
spiritual now at the time it was
definitely not my thing and i would say
it was kind of off plan and off path but
what the heck he said we should go to
this conference okay let's volunteer so
we can go for free okay that sounds like
a great idea you know i was sort of in a
seeking mode
that's when i met cheryl richardson who
spoke to the volunteers and she just
spoke and she was so dynamic
and i just thought what's that i want to
do that i could do that i saw myself in
her
so
i was sort of following her around the
whole conference and i thought i want to
become a coach in the meantime this
goldman thing was still happening in the
meantime i was being recruited by a
startup
and so
in the end i got the offer from goldman
to do private client services or private
wealth management or whatever it was
called and i ended up taking the job
with a startup
and i was i don't know the fourth
employee into the startup and after a
week or two i just thought oh oh
this was such a bad idea
it was sort of chaotic i didn't know
what i was doing they didn't know what
they were doing i just saw oh this is
this was like a bad decision it's quite
a transition from pwc too yeah and by
the way i just a handful of employees
yeah i just want to say that was also
before the startup world was so
mythologized it was before the startup
was oh the sexy startup it was a startup
why would you go do that even i didn't
know why i would do that but i just
thought i can't become a coach yet i'm
not experienced enough i gotta take
coach training and i thought oh startup
i can make a difference there a small
company i can make a difference so week
or two went by
and i just thought oh what a mistake
such a mistake so i screwed up this did
not happen easily i screwed up my
courage
and i got back in touch with the guy who
i talked to at goldman and i said
i just said straight up on the phone
i've made a mistake i should have taken
your job offer this was a bad idea i
would like to now reconsider
and he said no
he said no that was the opportunity you
had you made your choice and we had
actually a very cordial quite lovely
conversation and he gave me two gifts in
that
call he said you know alyssa you have a
superpower your superpower is that you
are very credible you show up instantly
credible
i didn't know that because i was feeling
pretty insecure i'll tell you and like i
didn't know what i was doing and the
second thing he said was
the reason i thought you'd be great for
this job is not because of your
background not because of your mba
but it was because you've done stand-up
comedy
and i know
that you have had to deal with rejection
and so i thought that that would be a
good attribute for this job let me ask
about those two real quick so stand-up
comedy
fit because in a sense you'd be
responsible for building your own book
of clients
right got it and incredible why do you
think he said that what does that mean
that you immediately came off as
credible
i think i have
a way
of
building rapport with people quickly
and kind of showcasing i guess i would
say confidence
i still as i say to my clients all the
time i don't know what it's like to be
with me i only know what it's like to be
me
however i do know that throughout my
life
i have been able to exhibit a certain
kind of energy that makes people follow
me
i mean i remember actually in
fourth or fifth grade
we were in homeroom and we were doing a
play so we were just kind of it's like a
free-for-all and the teacher wasn't
really involved so we the kids were all
putting together this play
and suddenly everybody came over to me
one at a time and said can i play this
part can i play this part can i play
this part and i i was really literally
consciously thinking why are you guys
asking me
i don't quite know
what it is but there are times that
people will come to me i guess because
of my energy or maybe the way i speak
i'm really not sure
but he pointed that out to me that was
helpful i love that the teacher was
absent from the play planning it's like
lord of the flies and then alyssa
decides
who's piggy and who gets crucified as
piggy
mutiny yeah luckily i was there tim
luckily luckily you were there to hold
the ship together you maintain order
well i think as i reflect on our
conversations and the time we spent
together that
you have a very
no [ __ ] demeanor and i think that
probably
translates to people feeling confidence
in what you say because if you don't
like something or you disagree with
something you're very open about that so
i think that gives people at least some
people a degree of
relaxation and comfort which might sound
strange but because they don't
second-guess what you're saying if that
makes
any type of sense
thank you for saying that tim and i feel
like you said it very diplomatically
which i appreciate you're welcome i'm
working on that diplomacy
that's good
but i do think
it's no [ __ ] and people say you're
very direct and i don't even think i'm
being direct i sometimes think i'm
trying to be less direct
i guess i come across as direct
that does seem to be a thing
cheryl richardson let's return to this
because for me
yeah if i think about
temperament
direct
quantitative with comfort with the
numbers through
business school and training for pwc etc
what was it
that appealed to you about coaching why
did it seem
right at first blush
in encountering shawl richardson to
appeal to you because that wouldn't be
something had i looked at your
trajectory up to that point it's not
something i would have at least from
what you've told me i wouldn't
immediately have guessed that
i have to be honest and i've thought
about this quite a bit i always think
what did she say
and i don't know what she said i have no
idea but she stood in front of the room
and she gave out this incredible energy
and it you felt like
you felt empowered after that energy
after that talk
and then i followed her around for the
rest of the conference and at some point
she was in a room with like 500 people
and she said okay who wants to stand up
right now and get coached and i thought
oh what's going to happen so someone
stood up and she coached this person
there in front of everybody for 20
minutes and i do remember vividly
thinking oh i could never do that but i
also thought oh i could do that i saw
that in myself
and i remembered i mean i sort of
realized that throughout my life people
have come to ask me for advice about
networking about careers
about problems they were having so i
sort of saw myself in that supportive
problem solver and definitely
to be someone who really makes people
feel like you can do it i sort of
recognize that i had that energy inside
of me
so let me for people who are wondering
give people a concrete example of one
way that you do this because there are
coaches who
disempower in the sense that they might
even be effective but they take the
agency of
like the locus of
control the agency from the athlete the
client the fill in the blank and sort of
become
the person who helps fix the other
person
and while
you
are very helpful
i know in our conversations and and
certainly i've seen you do this
elsewhere
if somebody asks you for advice on a
given situation
very often you'll respond with well what
do you think and they'll say i don't
know and then you'll respond with well
what if you did know
what might you say and it's incredible
how far
people can get on their own with just a
little prodding
and no side exit with that type of
reframing if that makes sense to people
listening i was just going to say thank
you for bringing that up and i really
try to
to your point give agency to other
people and
the truth is inside of you inside of
anybody
there's a whole chorus going on there's
a whole
music in your head going on and how
you're feeling
and
the person across from me you whoever it
is
knows more than they think they know
and i think people sort of say almost by
habit well what do you think somehow
you're the expert you're the coach but
actually
you do have a lot more internal wisdom
than you allow yourself
to
express and i think part of my role is
to encourage you to tap into that and
not let you take side exits especially
at first there's a sense of hey there's
more there let's be quiet for a minute
and reflect and see what's there
if you let it arise
okay so as we flash forward and flash
back we're doing this memento
style
architecture in this conversation
so mr goldman i know obviously not
called mr goldman but mr goldman says
actually that was your window so my
answer is now no but here are two
observations
within the startup
you've realized oh this was i was
supposed to take a right turn i took a
left turn this is probably not the best
fit right now
and shortly i guess beforehand you had
had this encounter with
cheryl richardson
what did you do then
first of all it was actually extremely
helpful that he said that to me
because i can get this way and i don't
think i'm alone it's like should i have
done that should i do that this was a
bad idea should i go back should i ask
him all this these questions which can
be kind of draining so i was actually
very happy and proud of myself that i
had gone back and asked
i was disappointed by his answer i was
actually quite crushed oh no what am i
going to do
but the clarity was so helpful i don't
have to now wonder should i have done
that i don't know did i make a bad
decision or also should i have asked him
if i could reconfigure this job offer i
was like nope that door is closed all
right now i know
so i went back to the startup and to be
honest with you it was fantastic it was
a great experience it was interesting
and fun and engaging was the first time
i ever met investors it was the first
time i saw what does a ceo do
also
i have a proactive nature and i was able
to express my proactive nature all these
things needed to get done
and so i kind of figured a lot of things
out by myself and with the company with
the rest of the employees and so
actually was fantastic it was so good i
joined a science startup what did the
first startup do it was called corporate
alumni so it was a very early precursor
of linkedin
amazing
which yeah which means timing is
everything
yeah timing timing timing is it is
important yeah i don't think you're
alone in the the the questioning
yourself and decisions and so on i was
joking with somebody
last night they were talking about their
onset insomnia and i was like oh you
mean when you're you lay down to go to
sleep and your mind is like oh thank god
we have some time i've been waiting all
day to talk to you here we go
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah
okay so i don't know if there are other
dots to connect
beforehand but at what point
did you take your pilgrimage to san
diego
was that years later was that shortly
thereafter
and also i should ask while you're
working at these startups were you
exploring in your off time the world of
coaching or did you really just chalk it
up to
a weird interesting experience that
grabbed your attention and that was that
end of story let me move on to my real
career in startups no in my mind's eye
whether it was conscious or not i was on
the path to coaching definitely
and
cheryl what should i do i followed
around the conference what should i do
should i take coach training so i took
coach training
and i coached all my friends i insisted
on coaching all my friends and i even at
some point i remember exactly one but i
hired my own coach but in the meantime i
left the first startup i went to the
second startup i was the cfo of for a
little while because the ceo came to
hire me to be the gm of the boston
office he was in california and he saw
on my resume he hadn't seen my resume
yet he saw in my resume that i was a cpa
and he said i see you're a cpa
and i said yeah
and he said you want to be the cfo
and i said
no i really don't and he said listen i
have a rent a cfo
she's robbing us blind i need you to
come to california and be the cfo for a
while you can hire a replacement and
then come back here to boston and be the
gm that was what they hired me for
and i said all right that's what i'll do
so that's what i did so i spent some
time there
as a cfo i kind of got things sorted out
and
it was of course a very good experience
and then i came back to boston and i was
the head of the boston office and it was
an incredibly good experience because i
kept telling myself you can't be a coach
yet you're too young you're too young
you don't have leadership experience
who's going to believe in you well
after a couple years in the startup
world you have leadership experience
so that was in 2000 time frame 2000 2001
and then of course the dot com exploded
in bloody waters exactly exactly so
everything exploded or imploded i should
say and they said they shut down the
boston office and they said come to
california we'll have a job for you here
and i said no i'm going to become a
coach now and that was like boom i'd
done all the things i've taken coach
training i'd hired my own coach i
coached all my friends and it was on
friday i'm going to become a coach and
on monday i became a coach that was my
couple of things to double click on
coaching your friends does this mean
coaching for free did you charge them or
you're like let me just get in reps i'm
going to learn
over the bodies of my early students
this is the battlefield
you know
how did you approach that i coached them
all for free in fact
they did not want the coaching i
insisted on coaching them i pushed
myself on them so i should have paid
them actually it's the truth
i got in reps to your point and then
after i mean i would say probably was
after i became a coach i began to coach
strangers for free
so it was no longer friends it was how
do i start with somebody who i've never
met before
did you just panhandle with like a will
coach for change how did you how did you
find these strangers
i asked my friends do you know anybody
who might want to coach for a period of
time i'm just a beginner so i'm not
going to be charging
and so i got referrals through that and
you get something out of it first of all
you get the experience but also if you
do a good job with them and they're
happy they refer you to other people
which they did who ultimately pay right
not just keep you can't make a living
actually coaching for free it turns out
and i went to a vendor fair at my gym i
remember vividly
and had people sign up to do an
introductory session with me so a lot of
people did this introductory session
with me and that was also to your point
getting in reps it was a feeling of
practicing how do you practice with
somebody
that's also when i saw that you can add
a lot of value very quickly for people
just by listening to what's going on
with them and responding and sort of
helping them sort out all the things
they're struggling with in their lives
okay so if we look at kind of present
day recent times we met through i don't
i don't know if if we should mention his
name
explicitly but we met through a mutual
friend an old friend of mine
who was in the process i guess when you
met him of building up his company
while you were together sold it for i
have no idea nine figures somewhere
so you went from vendor fair gym
to working with people like that c-suite
etc by the way i do want to talk about
pilgrimage to san diego let's go
directly to pilgrimage to san diego so
after i had become a coach and coached
all these people my vendor affairs and
finally found someone to some people to
start paying me
i started coaching i actually started
teaching and facilitating inside of a
large company and so from there i was
able to coach a lot of executives inside
this large company and i was like
awesome it was fantastic and i read
i read about this in the new yorker
magazine this incredible coach marshall
goldsmith who is well known as the
number one coach in the world and all
the trappings that come with that
16 years ago when i met him he was sort
of a big deal from this new yorker
article
i was flying to ireland
and i grabbed a book that he had edited
and i read the whole book and i was
upset about something and i read the
book like
oh okay and i sort of remembered oh yeah
this is why i love coaching oh yeah this
is what i can do and i flipped to the
back of the book and i thought
hey he's in san diego i had been anyway
toying with the idea of going to san
diego and i thought i'm gonna find him
i'm gonna find him while i'm in san
diego so i sort of networ when i got to
san diego i was going to be there for
three months in the winter
and i networked everywhere to try to
find him nobody knew him so i finally
just sent him an email and i said
marshall i'm in san diego for this
period i would love to meet with you
even if it's just for a little period of
time even if it's for a long time away
but i really would love to just come and
spend some time with you and a week
later he emailed me back
and i was able to kind of do my
pilgrimage to go see marshall goldsmith
the great marshall goldsmith in his home
in rancho santa fe california tell me
more about this email pitch because i
bet he received a lot of those and i
can't imagine he said yes to them all so
what else is in there why would he reply
to that why would he say yes you know
marshall is indeed a very generous
person and it turns out i'm not the only
one who met him through a cold email
it was a short email and i i'm sure i
described myself as in you know i'm a
coach oh i know i'm sure i said i'm a
coach
i saw the new yorker article that was
written about you i saw myself in that
and i'd love to come and meet with you
and see you and then i kind of let him
off the hook under any conditions that
will work for you a short period of time
any time you want so i think that that
prob all the combination of those things
is probably very helpful is there any
credibility line that you think helped
that email or was that absence where you
were like i've done work with a b and c
or i
blah nothing like that
no nothing that's that's incredible yeah
i wonder
even if he is generous i wonder if you
caught him in a
good window
just because there's a point where you
just can't physically respond to all of
those if you get a lot of them
so that's great that it worked out
i think you're right about timing i
think you know you can catch people in a
good window to your point and probably i
mean certainly he travels a lot so as it
happens he was around during this
particular period that was going to work
for both of us
so what happened
with marshall
so with marshall we took this walk eve
instead of come early in the morning so
i said okay i'll come early in the
morning he also suggested i bring a dog
treat for his dog beau which i followed
instructions good idea
and he walked me around this lake that
they had in rancho santa fe and it was
this beautiful lake this beautiful day
and we were talking talking talking
marshall's a great talker
and
at some point he said
alyssa how can i make your life better
and i thought oh i don't know which i'm
not prepared for this question i don't
know what to say
so i i said oh marshall i just want to
spend more time with you
marshall has himself benefited from a
lot of other people taking an interest
in him and giving him a chance so he was
talking about that and it just goes back
to your question why would he see me and
so i think he sees himself in other
people so he was talking to paul hersey
and how
he spent time with him we get back to
the driveway i'm about to get in the car
and i thought oh i know he's the big
mentor but you have to step up right now
so i said well marshall how can i make
your life better
and he said well
there's a project you could work on with
me i was like oh that's fantastic that's
wonderful
i'd love to do that and he said oh but
it's in new york and i said perfect
cause i live in boston i don't think he
quite realized i was only in san diego
for this three-month period
so i was like that's great he said okay
send me your resume and wait for further
instructions which i did and next thing
i know i was in the executive dining
room of this big bank in new york city
and meeting with the illuminati what
happened there
yeah well i was meeting i was meeting
with the ceo of this big bank and the
three of us it was me and him and the
ceo
and
he pretty much said this is alyssa she's
gonna be working with me and she's gonna
be part of the coaching team
so
that was the first time
i did anything with him and we worked
together pretty closely for a couple of
years
and he would bring me into engagements
he was working on and i would do this we
call it stakeholder centered feedback so
it's stakeholder centered coaching which
means 360 feedback from the folks around
the executive and i would do that
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know if you missed
10 of the best performing days after the
2008 crisis you would have missed out on
50 percent five zero percent of your
returns don't miss out on the best days
in the market stay invested in a
long-term automated investment portfolio
wealthfront pioneered the automated
investing movement sometimes referred to
as robo advising and they currently
oversee 20 billion dollars of assets for
their clients wealthfront can help you
diversify your portfolio minimize fees
and lower your taxes takes about three
minutes to sign up and then wealthfront
will build you a globally diversified
portfolio of etfs based on your risk
appetite and manage it for you at an
incredibly low cost wealthfront software
constantly monitors your portfolio day
in and day out so you don't have to they
look for opportunities to rebalance and
tax loss harvest to lower the amount of
taxes you pay on your investment gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account they've really
thought of a ton they've checked a lot
of boxes smart investing should not feel
like a roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you go to
wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today and
you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim wealthfront will
automate your investments for the long
term and you can get started today at
wealthfront.com
tim
this is a good time to pause and expand
on 360 feedback
so
you facilitated this for me and i found
it both valuable and absolutely crushing
it was like panic attack level
crushing i've had joe gebbia co-founder
of airbnb on this podcast before he
after his 360 feedback
i think he went to his car in the
parking lot and just cried in his car
yeah i think you have a story i don't
know the full story but i think you have
a story about a ceo in india which i'd
love to hear about
yeah within the context of describing
what 360 feedback is
i will describe it and then tim i'd love
to ask you actually
double click on what you just said in
terms of valuable and then also of
course very confronting but all it is is
when i'm working with somebody like in
your case for you i went to a number of
your employees and also business
associates and i ask people
three or four questions but the basic
questions are what is tim great at what
is his strongest strengths what does tim
need to get better at what are his
development opportunities and then what
specific behavioral suggestions do you
have for tim to help him be a better
leader better professional kind of
whatever that is and then we talk you
know when when i'm talking with somebody
of course i probe and ask for very as
specific as i can get because
you can say all day long this person
needs to be more collaborative or the
person needs to be more strategic or the
person should work on whatever
and i'm always interested in what
behaviorally would make you think that
because people have very different
definitions of what we think are common
words
right
right so i gather all that together and
i put together common themes
and specific quotes from people so
people can hear it so the executives i
work with can hear it in their own words
and the people around them and then we
sit down and talk through what they
found out so like in your case that we
sat down and we talked it through what
you found out about yourself both in
terms of your strongest strengths and
also your development opportunities and
then i love the suggestions because it
really gives you a road map
about what you should start doing and
stop doing behaviorally to make changes
in the eyes of the stakeholders
i think one of the mistakes i made if i
remember correctly because i know you
sent me and we talked about the feedback
which is all anonymized this is a really
important point and i think i was headed
on a trip or i can't remember exactly
what was happening but
i said something that i've said a lot
before that i now
take to be
untrue which is well the good stuff
takes care of itself so just send me all
like the critical
send me the hard stuff just just like
front load front load all the critical
stuff the good stuff will just take care
of itself it's already happening i don't
need to
fluff up my ego or puff up my chest like
just front load all the
development opportunities which is uh
like really putting a monkey in a suit
but it but it is better phrasing
and
i was not prepared for the level of
brutal honesty and detail i don't think
anyone is even if they say they are they
aren't
at least none of my friends who have
gone through this process seem to quite
be prepared for what they yeah receive
and it's valuable especially when there
are themes which almost inadvertently
there are
but very very challenging yeah and
i am curious about the ceo in india that
you've mentioned but not elaborated on
what are the most common responses
to
360 feedback
yeah so first of all the most common
response is just what you said which is
i don't care about the good stuff no i
don't care about that
and
i have to sometimes force it on people i
don't think i had to force it on you all
i think you paid you were sort of like
all right fine we're gonna do it your
way so you patiently waited for me to
get through the good stuff the strengths
it's very common that people want to
just get to the part where they can sort
of they need to change or fix something
the second is to your point it's
extremely common to be like
upset basically to be confronted right
it's very confronting when you see that
kind of stuff in black and white the ceo
i worked with in india we were sitting
in a conference room together and i gave
him the 360 and he was quite impatient
with the strengths like oh you're good
at this and you're smart and you're a
great motivator and you're able to lead
with influence which is not always
common for a ceo i mean it was fantastic
and then also the difficult stuff which
was you know he he was i remember he was
sort of motioning yeah yeah let's go
let's get to the difficult stuff let's
get to the development opportunities
okay so
turned out he was kind of a bully at
times he would sort of overreact to many
things and we had a list of things and
he listened to me he looked at the
papers
and he threw them down and he said this
is [ __ ] i'm gonna get to the bottom
of this
and he walked out of the walked out of
the conference which has never happened
to me either before which part was
[ __ ] was it the anonymizing or was
it something else the feedback what did
getting to the bottom of it mean in his
mind do you think
good question because i was thinking if
he goes back to his people
and confronts them with you said this
about me or you said that about me we
are sunk the reason we give
confidentiality to people the reason i
say to people i'm not going to say who
said what is for safety
so they don't feel like i can you know i
can talk about the boss and they don't
feel like they're going to get fired so
what if he goes out and starts asking
people did you say this did you say this
so i did not know what that meant i was
pretty freaked out i really was like i
don't know what's going to happen now so
i kind of waited
he came back
and he said i just called my wife and
she said it's all true
that's really funny
yeah one of the challenges i had was
well there were two of them
on one hand there were
there were some outliers i would say
with the understanding that my team is
not huge right i don't have a large team
but
there was some feedback that was highly
specific really uncomfortable
that i wanted to address but it was not
across the board for the team and since
it was anonymized and i didn't know who
provided the feedback i felt
paralyzed in a sense because like here
is an individual with a specific
complaint
and i can't fix it because i don't know
who it is or at least that was how i
felt the other issue was
being able to identify to triangulate
somehow be like okay i actually do know
who this is but i
i still don't feel like i can bring this
up with them directly because it was
provided under
the promise of confidentiality
right so i was like well what the [ __ ]
do i do with this then i had a lot of
trouble yeah emotionally with it and
ultimately there were actionable things
and we could put together a plan but
man i'm sure you remember i really had a
very very tough time with it yeah which
i guess going into it if the expectation
is set that
by the way most people or a lot of
people have a lot of trouble with this
then
i don't feel quite as
judgmental about my response to it
well there's a lot here it's fascinating
what you're saying and i of course i
remember that and i remember that with a
lot of compassion
especially because to your point
just it's very confronting for most
people and they have their different
ways of reacting to it many people get
quite defensive at first i remember your
reaction was definitely just quite kind
of brought up a lot of anxiety for you
as i recall yeah i was just like well
what the [ __ ] do i do with all this
because it was like we had a lot of
feedback i was like i can't remember 15
20 pages i don't know it felt like 15 or
20 pages but i think it was i mean it
was a lot of feedback positive and
negative but for me
and this is a weakness of mine i don't
think i've received a lot of positive
feedback in my life so i discount it i
just like yeah i don't need that i don't
need that right like just
if i'm scoring 97 on the test i need to
fix the other three points not the other
97 so what's the negative feedback or
the i want to know the development of
opportunities and
it wasn't immediately clear to me that i
could do anything without being able to
correlate
and discuss the feedback to specific
people if that makes sense so it was
very i had a lot of anxiety i definitely
did
and i remember that was the that was
sort of the day of the day after in
particular that we talked about it and
maybe a couple of things also
i don't think that we were as rigorous
about this with you as i typically am
with the ceos i work with which is to
send them back to the stakeholders and
to say
here's what i found out and to send back
to all the stakeholders because again
it's anonymous so you can talk about the
themes that i found out and then here's
what i'm going to do about it
and that actually is a connective tissue
okay so i got all this feedback so now
what do i do with it and opening up the
dialogue with the stakeholders is
actually very it's very healing it takes
taboo topics off the table it actually
then helps people say in their own words
what's going on it helps the ceo if this
was really not a topic for you but it
helps the ceo if necessary apologize to
people like i didn't realize i was
coming across that way so in many ways
that process it's a starting point of
getting the feedback itself and then
sending them back to the stakeholders to
have open-ended conversations about what
they found out what they're going to do
about it
bridges the gap between the feedback and
then the response but i guess i'm
wondering about you tim could you talk
about what was valuable about it and
what did you change as a result of it
well i think that
there are certain themes that came back
not surprisingly so
since i have not historically received a
lot of positive feedback i tend not to
give a lot of positive feedback
there were a number of themes like that
that were
self-evident in their importance
it just took
the reinforcement of multiple people
saying something similar to really
drive the point home that something
needed to be done about that
also i think that as someone who has
worked remotely most of his life
it's easy for me to forget how helpful
team cohesion can be yeah yeah and with
a distributed team also i think it's
easy for me to take that for granted
because i just i tend to
i think do better than most in an
isolated environment i just don't need
as much
i think i'm bizarre in that way i just
have some mutation
where i don't require as much socially i
require quite a bit environmentally but
not socially so seeing those things
as themes as opposed to one-off comments
by individuals distributed over a long
period of time was helpful
to then sit down and say okay what am i
going to put in my calendar
because if it's not my calendar it's
just not real what am i going to put in
my calendar
to block out time to start to
address some of these things or develop
certain habits that counter balance
other things so i think in those ways it
was very helpful i required a cooling
off period before i could get there
yeah
and to be clear it wasn't so much anger
at
employees
or team members it was
it wasn't obvious to me immediately how
to
fix these problems or even that they
were fixable since i couldn't have
specific conversations with specific
people i think that is where i had the
most struggle at the time
and i think that's from speaking with
friends who have done this
i think that's pretty common feeling
maybe it's magnified or maybe it's
lessened by having a smaller team i
don't know
and there's certainly you know other
things that we've done that
i've found helpful that perhaps you
could speak to like the pre-mortem as
opposed to the postmortem
could you speak to what that is
people know what a post-mortem is like
let's debrief how this went
but i work with my clients and also
thinking about him pre-mortem so
thinking about
let's assume that this doesn't go well
this fails in some way or doesn't
fulfill the promise
what are the things that we did
that made it fail and if you can
anticipate those in advance you have a
much better way a much better hope of
planning to not have those things one of
my clients did this
they were doing a partnership with a
larger company
and the pre-mortem was
all the things that are going to prevent
us from winning from doing it right and
one was lack of communication
so my client that i was coaching from
the startup
she realized ah okay
i need to proactively make sure that i'm
going to put meetings on the calendar
that are going to contain all of us
project meetings that contain all of us
on a regular basis now what normally
happens in any kind of company oh we're
too busy we're good we don't need those
meetings no we're all set but she really
insisted
because she sort of saw it's going to be
easy for us to get off track on this
project and it really helped them all
stay on the same page and also help them
build relationships so that when things
got bad and you know when things sort of
got rough and they did
the relationship amongst all the team
members who were working together was
much better
so that's an example of the way you can
use a pre-mortem i think the phrasing is
really important
as always
because
you know the words reflect
the questions we ask reflect the
precision or lack of precision in our
thinking
rather than saying what could go wrong
what could go wrong saying let's assume
six months from now the project has
failed
yeah
first of all that forces you to define
what failure is and what success
is respectively so let's assume six
months from now this project has failed
what does that look like
and then what are the most likely causes
what are the things that most likely
contribute to that and walking through
if you were to create the perfect recipe
for
producing this failure what would the
steps look like what would the
ingredients be
super super super helpful
i want to touch on a couple of other
points so we can digress i should say we
should we can weave we can weave this
conversation
in any non-linear way that we like but
you are very good at keeping
people on point which presupposes there
is a point in conversations and meetings
could you speak to
establishing agendas or goals for
meetings how do people actually
ensure
that
meetings are valuable because there are
also many people listening to this no
doubt who look at their calendar for the
week and they're like for [ __ ] sake
i have eighty percent of my time blocked
out for meetings what is happening in
these meetings
or i wish i could not be at some of
these meetings
how do you make a productive meeting i
am always astounded at meetings and how
inefficiently they're run and how much
we waste our time in meetings i'm always
like guys it's an expensive room right
like actually it matters that we're all
here and kind of meandering off course
so when i'm there or what i always try
to do is get people to do this hopefully
you know when i'm not there to get into
the habit of saying what's the goal of
this meeting what is the purpose of this
meeting specifically and what does
success look like we're going to come
out of this meeting with and then some
definition of success and then how are
we going to get there so when i often
will say to people what's the goal of
the meeting they kind of list out an
agenda first we're going to talk about
this then we're going to talk about this
and actually
what's interesting to me is that it
takes a minute for me to have them step
back and say no really what's the goal
of this meeting like what's what is the
outcome you're looking for
not just the tools not just the agenda
you're going to go through that one yeah
we're making pound cake or carrot cake
don't just list the ingredients like
what are we making right
right right exactly that's it right or
we're making pound cake or spaghetti
because it's right it's like two
different things so
what they'll say is we're trying to make
decisions on the set in the other and
i'll say okay so you've got 20 people in
this meeting are you really going to
make a decision in this meeting is that
really what you're going to do are you
set up to make a decision has everyone
thought about it
oh no not really okay who do you
actually need to make a decision
well these five people oh okay great and
what do they need to make a decision
well
they need this kind of material this
kind of insight fantastic so the
decision making meeting the sort of
we're going to decide this thing is a
different meaning by the way tim if that
meeting's happening now
then what we can do is shift the goal of
this meeting it doesn't have to be
irrelevant the goal of this meeting may
be is to lay the table for that decision
how's that so maybe it's to get everyone
on the same page maybe it's to prime
everybody the decisions about to be made
maybe it's to have everybody go off and
do some more work to come back to the
table to think about the decision that's
okay
but then we have to be clear the purpose
of this meeting is to communicate and
prime people and that's a different
meeting is going to happen some
different is going to happen to make a
decision
i'm obsessed with meetings as you can
see i love meetings
uh yeah
good meetings are great well that's part
of the reason that i have hired you to
help with offsites before uh my favorite
thing in the world could you speak to
off-sites
and let's frame it for people because
perhaps if they work in a large company
chances are
that offsites have either been figured
out or they haven't
but if we're talking about smaller teams
just for the sake of
argument to make it not argument but for
the sake of discussion to make it
concrete let's just say it's
teams of 10 to 20 people
startups fast growing startups
right currently 10 to 20 employees
how would you encourage people to think
about
to offsite or not to offsite
let's just assume we are post-covered
concern
and
then if the decision is too off-site
how to think about formatting such a
thing i like to think of myself as
somebody who doesn't over-prescribe
as a coach i don't walk into a situation
and say let's do an off-site we need to
have an offsite no no no first of all
i'm involved so what i'm finding are a
few symptoms and the symptoms might be
people are not on the same page people
don't understand the goals there's not
maybe a strong relationship between key
people to your point of action about
team cohesion it's just not an esprit de
corps
so what that means is all of those
things get in the way of work and get in
the way of kind of rowing in the same
direction so that's what i would say to
the ceo i'm working with a leader i'm
working with let's do an off-site
now as i recall tim you were a little
skeptical
i was i was i was i mean this just comes
back to not
recognizing that my norm is not normal
right i mean i just i have certain
mutations and don't get me wrong they're
not all enabling i have some crippling
deficits but
i was skeptical i was like yeah do we
really need this i mean we live in a
digital distributed world people are
doing their work we have the sauna we
have slack we have these tools
what are we going to do in the off site
i mean is this i don't i don't quite
understand
the value so yes i was very skeptical
yeah but so you actually not to my
credit i did it
you did it
what made you agree to do it
do you remember uh you know i think that
for
a lot of things like this ultimately it
came down to what's the max downside and
is there possible upside if so what
might those upsides be and then just
looking at it and concluding that it's
an experiment worth conducting
i hadn't decided that it was a bad idea
i hadn't decided either that it was a
good idea but i came to the conclusion
kind of weighing the pros and cons that
it was a worthwhile experiment
yeah like what the heck let's just try
it yeah why not yeah
and i think that actually you are not
alone so many of the ceos i work with or
any of the leaders i work with if they
haven't experienced offsites or
people may have experienced as a
negative either waste of time or weird
trust falls or uncomfortable or not
productive
i typically
have a little ways to go to help
persuade them influence them that it's a
good idea to your point to try
so for me what i like to do is i use
data as in this is my experience of the
team so the team doesn't know as i said
before the things going on it'll be
really helpful to get everybody on the
same page it'll be helpful to do this
one particular working session in where
we step outside the day-to-day and do it
together in a concentrated period of
time but at the end of the day tim just
like you they're like all right let's
try it so then we try it and it's to me
it's the same thing what's the goal of
this offset so it's a one day offset a
two-day offset what's the specific goal
that we want to get out of this and by
the way team cohesion having some laughs
together enjoying being together that's
part of it that's a fantastic goal
especially by the way coming out of
covet that's a fantastic goal right now
just to kind of reconnect but then it
may also be
to plan the year or it may also be to
think through how we're working as a
team and to improve we're working
together as a team and it may also be
specific projects that the team is
working on that'll just again benefit
from
a quiet reflective space together it
really
struck me
after the fact is so clearly valuable
also in establishing a
feeling of
team
for a distributed team
who individually otherwise can feel very
very isolated
right and this is particularly true i
think in
my team where there's not a whole lot of
overlap it's not like i have five people
working in one division 20 people
working in another i have very clearly
defined roles and they don't overlap
very much and therefore people can kind
of feel like they're on an island
interacting with me
on a somewhat
minimal level via phone and certainly
via
facetime
in person or otherwise and
that
that can be really hard for people
really really hard for people and
i also found it really enjoyable
surprise surprise tim also likes to be
social sometimes and
breaking bread and having meals and
bullshitting and cracking jokes and and
having interaction that is not limited
to
all right what's the status on x what
are the next steps on why
was
really helpful to the
fortify the health of the
collective so to speak that was
surprised
yeah i remember you were surprised i
even remember this feeling of oh you're
having fun that's good that's good i
think your team was way into it and no
one knew what to expect really
but i appreciate that you have come to
see the value of the feeling of enjoying
being together as being actually
tangibly helpful for the team to work
together
yeah yeah absolutely that's great yeah
that was fun it was fun and uh you know
i wanted to read something that speaking
of my team so that was just sent by
someone on my team because i asked them
for it
that is related to wasted time in
meetings and this is from john arnold
who's an incredible incredible investor
very very effective philanthropist also
in 2000 i think 2007 he became the
youngest billionaire in the
u.s
and has a fascinating story and in fact
my friend peter tia dr peter tia
interviewed
john arnold on his podcast and i
encourage people to
listen to it
he
started a firm called centaurus advisors
is a long time ago which was a
houston-based hedge fund specializing in
trading energy products
amazing story really really fascinating
guy and he was in tribe of mentors and
i think the question he was responding
to is something you know what have you
come to appreciate
or do more or think more about as you've
grown older
and here's his answer it's pretty short
i had not appreciated the maximum time
as money until recently which is
surprising right coming from someone of
this level of accomplishment
so he continues but for those whose time
is a scarce resource learning to say no
to meetings is a necessary skill sitting
through an unproductive meeting has huge
opportunity cost it seems obvious
but people struggle with equilibrating
time and money and this is the part that
really stuck out for me
it actually still kind of pains me to
read this because i recognize it also in
myself
there are many organizations that fret
over small direct expenses yet have no
misgivings about keeping superfluous
staff tied up in a conference room for
hours
and in recent years i've become better
at judging the opportunity cost of time
but it's true right so it's easy to
scrutinize an expense report and be like
wait a second why the hell did such and
such cost two grand in the meantime
the calendar is just clogged full of
meetings where staff time is just
spinning
totally at an alarming rate and racking
up incredible time cost and that was in
his profile and tribe of mentors but
yeah
so i appreciate and i value
how you are able to help extract
and ensure high value from meetings
because it's another thing that i've had
i think in many cases a reasonable bias
against but i have come to appreciate
that there are times and places where
they can be run very effectively and
there are techniques they're tools for
doing that
yes can i say one thing about that quote
which was fantastic yes it's that we
have so you're holding these people
hostage you're holding the staff hostage
in these meetings and of course your
hoarding time it should be unlocked to
have them go do other things but also
it's like you're crushing their soul
because they know that they shouldn't be
in this meeting because they're like oh
i have so much work to do and i'm in
this meeting and it's just draining
people don't
feel burned out because they're working
long hours or they're working hard
people feel burned out when they're
wasting their time when things are hard
to do or when they're spending their
time
in these endless meetings that don't
feel relevant to them so i think that's
part of the unlock is also it's to be
efficient and effective in your meetings
and it's also to recognize that people
should be freed and unlocked to go do
their work and they're going to be
happier when they're putting their time
and effort into things that matter
yeah for sure for sure i mean if i look
at the times when i am
energetically under-resourced and
exhausted
it's not when i'm working really hard on
something i care about
or something i'm excited about it's when
i'm dying to death by a thousand paper
cuts
right or locked into something that i'd
prefer not to be doing
thankfully not very often but it does
happen
so let's also talk about one of your
strengths which i have personally
benefited from i know a lot of my
friends who have worked with you also
benefit from and that is scripts
and
my friend ramit seti has scripts for all
sorts of things related to personal
finance and they work right so if you
want to renegotiate your
credit card fees or whatever it might be
or you want to ask for a certain favor
from your bank there are simply scripts
that work better than others
and
i'd like to
talk about a couple of them you have
scripts for
a million different things you actually
have these scripts
in
your book so for people who want a full
repository of these scripts
that have been refined
over time from startup to grown up is
the book so pick that up well let's talk
about an uncomfortable situation in the
work context and for
my team who's listening to this is not
because any of you are falling in this
category just to be just to be clear how
to give someone feedback
about the fact that they're not
addressing
feedback you've already given them
yeah or that you've given them multiple
times
so what i think oftentimes the clients i
work with and really any let's think of
a ceo of a startup that i work with his
point of view to me is i keep telling
him i've told him i've told him multiple
times i've told him he's not doing it so
then i'm like let's step back because
your job is not to nag people that's
terrible this feeling of like oh i'm the
nag now. now to me it gets interesting
and i like to give people a framework
which is content pattern and
relationship so content pattern and
relationship so content is cpr
cpr exactly exactly
so the content is
the thing that they're doing let's
assume that your
vice president of product
is not communicating with the people
around him he's kind of like living in a
in a silo and we need your information
to feed into sales to feed into
marketing even to feed into engineering
and you're not proactively telling
people what you're thinking and what's
going on so that's the feedback and i
need you to proactively tell your people
tell your peers what's going on and then
life goes on and he doesn't do it and
the c goes back and says hey i really
need you to proactively tell your peers
what's going on it's really they need
this information it's really important
so it doesn't happen again and rather
than keep going back it's really helpful
to say hey
i've been seeing a pattern so i've been
asking you to proactively reach out to
your peers and tell them what's going on
it's actually really important because
they need the input
and you've told me yes yes yes a couple
of times but i'm seeing this pattern
which is that i ask you to do it and
maybe you get better for a day or two
but it doesn't stick
what's going on
and that's the conversation to have with
people not this constant sort of do this
okay do this okay do this it's like
doesn't help at some point they're not
doing it what's going on
yeah
how do you see those conversations
unfold
what do people say
actually the first reaction is usually i
know i know i'm sorry i know i know but
that's the problem is that we're
focusing again on content
then i ask my clients to actually role
play with me
let's talk about the pattern what's
going on
and do you think it's important yeah i
know it's important i get busy i forget
and then let's talk about strategies
that i actually need you to use and i'm
here to help you but i actually need to
use these strategies to remind yourself
to coordinate better with them you need
to have sort of a small peer team
meeting periodically every day or once a
week do you need to put on your calendar
that you need to kind of let people know
on mondays and thursdays what's going on
do you need to have more one-on-ones
with these folks whatever it takes but i
can't have you keep forgetting if that's
what's going on
okay let's say
strike one strike two strike three
this conversation strike 37
flash forward
what do
you what do the firing conversations
look like
after a period of time if this person is
not performing they're just not
performing they're either not
communicating in this way
they're not managing their area so for
example a lot of people inside of
startups they start out as a product
manager as an example and then they turn
into the head of product which means
they're no longer a product manager
that's not their job anymore their job
is to lead hire and lead a team of
people very different skill set and it's
very common for someone who's a great
product manager to get promoted into
this head of product and then bad things
happen as i said
so problems problems everywhere as you
also said exactly exactly problems
problems everywhere well the problems
problems everywhere is like yep as soon
as you solve this problem you're gonna
solve another problem so let's solve
this problem first you don't ever
graduate from problems
so
you then look at this person and you say
listen and maybe you've had a few more
conversations
and i'll talk about sort of you're not
building and leading your team i've
asked you a couple of times to really
focus on building and leading your team
to make sure that everybody's
coordinated together and that we're
launching two or three products not just
this one product i've asked you to learn
to delegate more to get people more
involved and i've asked you to
communicate around to people
let's assume that this person has not
addressed any of your feedback or has
not adequately addressed it maybe
they're trying maybe they're not trying
it needs to be a different conversation
which is listen i've asked you to do
these things it hasn't been working i
need to let you know that we're going to
part ways with you we can talk all about
why and how
and i want to make sure it's going to be
a good transition i think you're a great
person it's just that you're not able to
meet the job requirements right now and
it's really necessary to have the people
in place to meet the job requirements so
i want to talk to you about the
transition plan
the thing is that i assume that you've
had a lot of conversations in advance of
that because it should not be a surprise
for somebody when they ultimately get
fired if that's what happens it's
because you've had the conversations
with them time and time again content
pattern
and you're able to then say we've had
this conversation multiple times it's
not working i need to make a different
decision we need to part ways
are there any
books or resources
that you recommend
for getting better at having difficult
conversations
or uncomfortable conversations i should
say because not all
uncomfortable conversations are
difficult
aside from the fact that most people
avoid
and would prefer not to feel discomfort
but they're not necessarily complex
they're just very uncomfortable
uncomfortable exactly i think a
fantastic resource is crucial
conversations
which is then followed up by crucial
confrontations
his companion book so actually i often
think that
people think that confrontations are
like oh i don't want to confront him
well i think you're just saying here's
what's going on it's not about
confronting people i think sometimes
people confuse direct talk and straight
talk with confrontations nonetheless
crucial conversations and crucial
confrontations give you a lot of tools
into how to address those conversations
and i would add radical candor by kim
scott is also a great book on that from
that point of view because it also makes
the case about why it's so important to
give feedback for people
radical candor is really clear in you
need to build a solid relationship with
people which is absolutely true
conversations go better when you have a
solid relationship with someone and they
know that you're on their side and that
you're doing this because you want to
help them give them the feedback because
you want to help them and then
it helps you really have the tools to
actually say what there is to say in a
comfortable way well not in a
comfortable way but in a less
uncomfortable way radical candor
has
the author one more time please kim
kim's kim scott kim scott
yeah
she's a grid and i don't remember all
the parts of her grid but one of her
grid the place you did not want to be is
ruinous empathy do you feel so bad for
them so you don't want to say and then
20 years go by and their career doesn't
get better because you were not
comfortable telling them what had to be
said
so radical candor not to be confused
with radical honesty although they sound
very similar they're very very different
i think they're actually both
worth kind of digging into but it made
me think for a second just for a little
comedic relief of an article that a
friend of mine named aj jacobs wrote for
esquire magazine which is actually a
really good article called the headline
is i think you're fat and then the
subtitle is this story is about
something called radical honesty it may
change your life but honestly we don't
really care by aj jacobs
and aj for those who don't know will
undertake these
often absurd often also profound in some
ways
experiments of sorts much to the
suffering of his poor wife who's great
but it's also a good compliment it sort
of highlights the risks and benefits of
radical in this case radical honesty but
radical candor i actually haven't heard
of that book before so i'm excited to
take a look at it kim scott i'd like to
share a story where this became really
real for me it was please
just from a client a few years ago
he
was
the cfo
of the company that i was working with
and we would talk and by the way what a
fantastic guy and also was so empathetic
that was hard for him to give feedback
to people
so
he had his direct report who was never
you know a number of things that she
wasn't doing right she wasn't
owning a process she wasn't proactively
giving updates she would never speak
publicly so there was you know all these
reasons why she was kind of getting in
her own way and we talked about
i said well maybe you need to give her
that feedback and he said oh no i know
what's going to happen she's going to
cry no i don't want to do that no
and i said you know you're observing
this important area for her to grow in
her career
and it's so stingy of you to hold back
because you're not comfortable that's
what i hear you saying i'm going to be
uncomfortable and i'm gonna make her
uncomfortable and i just said you know
you're you're robbing her of the benefit
so we role play he agree we've
role-played it he went and talked to her
they had a very
difficult conversation it was difficult
not because she was against the feedback
but because she did cry
and because she did talk about her
concerns it's really hard for me to do
this and it's hard for me to do that
it's hard for me to speak publicly it's
hard for me to remember to keep track of
all these things i don't always feel
empowered to kind of go do this thing on
my own they had a long conversation
she was upset
and the next day she came back to him
and said i so appreciate you telling me
that i know that was hard i so
appreciate you telling me that i wish
somebody had told me all this 15 years
ago
and i just thought oh we have so much
work to do
problems problems everywhere
yes
yes
yes and you got to pick which problems
you're going to solve now
and if you solve the hyundai of problems
congratulations now you get the mercedes
of problems if you solve that
congratulations you get the bugatti
problems but you're still going to have
things to work on it's true i tell my
clients if you're lucky you pick your
problems problems problems everywhere
but if you're lucky you get to pick your
problems if you don't like these
problems why don't you go join ibm
right because you've got a whole other
set of problems right with being in a
large company besides being in your
startup so if you like these problems
let's solve these problems these are the
problems you've chosen for yourself
for sure and as
chris bosh legendary basketball player
said recently on the podcast he said
just imagine you put all your problems
on the table with everyone else's
problems you'll probably pick up your
problems really quickly
yeah that's probably true yeah yeah so a
couple of other things i have in my
notes here that i wanted to explore one
is
i think it extends well beyond personal
brand but the the approach to personal
brand of asking people what are the
three words you think about when you
think about me
could you elaborate on that please i
love that i think that's such a quick
and easy 360 feedback a little bit it's
like how am i showing up so for
everybody
tim you're the expert on your intention
and everybody around you is the expert
on your impact for all of us it's so
helpful to figure out how am i showing
up because we never really know how
we're showing up so this three words
activity first of all i want to tell
everybody
you can always say
oh i heard a coach and she told me to do
this blame me that's what i always
wanted it's a little weird
what you're about to do is a little
weird and if you're not doing it inside
your organization it's going to be like
wait why are you doing this i heard a
coach okay great so
you can email this to folks you might
want to set it up like i'm i'm gathering
information about me i'm trying to
advance my career one thing that really
helped me would be if you could
articulate the three words that you
think about when you think about me
and now people regularly say you mean
your strengths and weaknesses no no just
looking for the three words and so if
you can email that to folks or if you
can ask them then they'll give you back
three words so i did this one of my
clients and she had said to me
i'm very strategic i'm like great that's
fantastic and she told me that quite a
bit
and i said well let's do the three-word
activity so i actually did it for her i
went out and i said when you think about
my client what are the three words that
come to mind when you think about her
and a lot of words came back detailed
critical
thoughtful analytical
methodical
but strategic
did not show we asked probably eight or
ten people and strategic did not show up
so i said well i'm just letting you know
i know that you're strategic in your own
head but i just want you to know that's
numb that brand is not getting out there
people are not viewing you as strategic
and i think that's common tim because
people think these thoughts in their
head they think
but
really what people observe is action
they observe your communication and they
observe what you do
so you've got to realize that that's
what they have to draw on for you and
make sure that you're doing things which
are in alignment with the three words
that you want them to say
i sent this out to 10 people recently
and no one came back with enlightened i
was very disappointed
carry water carry water
this type of exercise is
can be so powerful and it can take many
forms but this type of feedback so that
you can try to
compare the image of yourself in your
own
mind or ego with the image of yourself
the perception of you in the wider world
is so
valuable and as some are more painful
than others i mean i think that you know
the 360 feedback is like a
360 sort of psychic colonoscopy it's not
always fun very valuable the three words
is a pretty sort of lightweight
appetizer approach
and i also remember
for myself you know it only occurred to
me right now
and popped into my mind but when i was
in high school i must have been 15 or 16
i was probably 16.
and i read a book called mental
toughness training for sports by
someone named jim lehrer who much much
much later decades later actually had on
the podcast l-o-e-h-r and he's worked
with all sorts of top level athletes
brand names that everyone would
recognize so i did this inventory in
that book
which was
similar to 360 feedback in so much as
there were maybe 10 or 20 questions and
you you would give these out to people
who knew you really well in different
capacities peers coaches etc it was
intended for
in this case sports so teammates but
that really changed my life it was
even at 15 or 16 it was so
shocking and enlightening
and actionable to get that kind of
feedback so i love the three words
exercise which is also an easy way for
people to kind of dip their toe in the
water before they
upgrade to the more aggressive
possibilities
right the nuclear approach yeah yeah
exactly
tim can i ask you what did you find out
from that activity and then how did you
use it way back
when i did this i i wish i had a better
memory of the exact questions but
it was an assessment of weaknesses and
strengths
and
you would see patterns in terms of
weaknesses but not just weaknesses but
things that you should work on so okay
fine we all have weaknesses you don't
actually need to fix all of them most of
the time and if you look at some
incredible athletes i mean they have
huge weaknesses but they know how to
capitalize on their strengths but if
they have a weakness that is
in some way
handicapping their strengths then there
might be a bigger issue so it was really
helpful in an unemotional kind of
clinical way almost like there were
anthropologists looking at this creature
called tim
to simply note like yeah not great at
endurance or hasn't developed this
physical attribute or in this particular
training capacity like could do better
in this following way in practice
and simply to see a consensus of some
type
was really helpful to me because i had a
few blind spots and
for all of those reasons found it really
really valuable i love that you know as
you know i'm very into fitness and i'm
into kettlebells and so
my coach who works with me on my
strength training and my kettlebells one
time i failed a lift
and
he looked at me so kindly and he said so
almost like joyfully oh good
now we know where the gaps are
yeah and i thought that was so beautiful
that he looked at my failure right my
weakness that way
and it changed actually my way to think
about as much as possible i try to give
people a lot of tools
to handle it to your point kind of
clinically or even as oh good now we
have something to do
yeah these reframes are really helpful
because life can be such a
disaster sometimes or it can just be
seen as such like an unrelenting barrage
of like a hailstorm of [ __ ] that
when you have these experiences these
reframes can make all the difference and
yeah i wanted to also because this came
up to my mind earlier but a quote from
janet levin who's an astrophysicist
here's her quote i used to resent
obstacles along the path thinking if
only that hadn't happened life would be
so good then i suddenly realized life is
the obstacles there is no underlying
path and i just find that very
reassuring
and you know another reframe that that i
found
helpful maybe a lens through which to
look at these experiences like a failed
lift or something else
came from jim detmer who's great and has
been really helpful to me and when i
will have some
blow up or
what i perceive is just a miserable
failure or just some complete
d-minus
report card grade back on whatever i
attempted to do
or i'll lose my temper or i'll get
really sad or i'll start beating myself
up and and describe that to him it'll
say great that's a pop quiz from the
universe like all the stuff we've been
working on like great you just had a
test so let's look at what happened
and
it's like oh yeah oh yeah i'm not in the
dojo so i can like practice karate kicks
in the dojo this is actually supposed to
be used for something okay yeah let's
look at
the pop quiz from the universe and the
report card and exactly as you said like
great how do we know what the gaps are
okay let's see let's work on that
the pop quiz from the universe yeah i
love that yeah yeah i didn't study i'm
not ready yeah yeah sorry sorry oh there
wouldn't be quizzes yeah you caught me
you caught me i didn't read up on that
math
could you speak to
self-talk
and specifically
how do you move from and why should you
move from
some of the more critical self-talk
to
let's just say and this is in my notes
here you know i will be okay no matter
what and
when did that
become important to you personally and i
realize there's a lot packed into that
one compound question so take it
wherever you'd like you know i am
somebody
to your point before like i'm on the
forced march of my life many times and
so my self-talk can be oh you didn't do
that right you screwed that up my woe is
me self-talk is what will become of me
and
i began to realize that that you know
you think it's nothing you think it
doesn't matter it's not in the physical
world or uh who cares what you say to
yourself or no i don't really talk to
myself or whatever
but once you become aware of it actually
i i have my clients do this and i've
done this myself in the middle of the
day
you could journal
what has motivated me and energized me
so far
and what has demoralized me and made me
feel bad so far today and de-energized
me
and very often it's self-talk so it's
like i did this thing and i told myself
i did this great job that's fantastic
that was energizing and then coming to
terms with what you tell yourself when
you screw something up or you got a d
minus or something on the test so
i think just coming to terms with the
fact that self-talk is real and i began
to study a little bit about it and i saw
research articles that said
that athletes athletes talk to
themselves and they see that when they
say motivating things to themselves they
perform better and when they say
demotivating things to themselves they
perform worse
and i thought well i don't need much
more information than that i'm convinced
and then i see it in myself and in my
clients and so i just want to say to
everybody
many people i work with are critical and
are very hard on themselves
and
i think that they think it gives them an
edge i know you've talked about that a
lot before on your podcast you think it
gives you an edge but
actually self-compassion and
transforming that negative self-talk
into something more positive into
reframes finding ways to reframe it into
more positive
telling yourself positive things even in
the face of that negative self-talk it's
actually very helpful because it gives
you a ton more energy and i found that
for myself totally and maybe it gives
you an edge but it's like trying to chop
vegetables holding the kitchen knife by
the blade it's like yeah
you're pointing it the wrong way
you're not you're not doing it right
right
i think it leads to a downward spiral at
times you think it gives you an edge but
i am not sure if that edge is helpful in
performance because what do you care
about success whatever that your domain
is you want to be successful so the
problem is when you
talk down to yourself when you criticize
yourself especially harshly you're
actually burning up a lot of calories
which you could have used to actually
solve the problem you're not your most
resourceful you're not your most
creative and best self when you
yeah and you can still have really high
standards if we look objectively at any
type of mammalian training whether it's
dog training dolphin training human
training
overwhelming negative feedback
generally does not work very well and
there's a great book called don't shoot
the dog terrible title great book by uh
it's karen pryor that i recommend to
everybody
self-talk is you know one sort of pillar
of
not just mental health but mental
performance that i've tried to pay more
and more attention to you know a friend
of mine very well-known guy who people
would know
has worked with therapists and used i
want to say it's dialectic or
dialectical behavioral therapy
and as part of that
done an exercise where
when he catches himself berating himself
with self-talk he stops
pulls out his phone to use voice memo
records
self-talk
as if he were talking to his best friend
or say
a younger child
and then sends it to his therapist and
that's more for accountability than
feedback although there is feedback also
and did this for a number of weeks and
it changed how he
spoke to himself
and in terms of the degree of harshness
versus kind of support and encouragement
makes a huge difference wow
wow that's a huge difference
self-talk
is and i just want to mention this
because i think it's a useful framework
or just a mnemonic device
is
one of
what you refer to as the three selves or
the three selfs you have self-awareness
self-compassion and self-talk and i
think if you if you're checking those
off
kind of like you check off
the food groups for a given day or
exercises you need to do
we would all be better off not just
individually but collectively so i did
want to mention that i don't know if
there's anything you want to add to that
but you know self-awareness
self-compassion self-talk like you can't
have any of those without self-awareness
that's kind of a prerequisite for
the other two but is there anything
you'd like to add to that
i just want to add the bridge of
self-compassion which i think is so
important again it's like people are oh
no i don't i don't want to waste that
time i just want to fix the problem i
actually think internally
gosh the image is coming to mind like
internally hugging yourself
actually knowing hey i'm doing the it's
part of self-talk really i'm doing the
best i can
i don't mean to be
screwing up whatever is i think i'm
screwing up
i'm going to keep trying
until i get it right
the compassionate parent
looking into that self
and giving some comfort that lets you
move to the next stage which is
self-talk it's becoming aware of it it's
then giving yourself the healing power
of compassion just knowing hey we're all
here doing the best we can and so are
you
that allows you and gives you the space
to open up and transform yourself talk
and by the way
if you're hard on yourself as ceos i
work with they can be very hard on
themselves they can be very critical the
problem is in addition to taking up your
time and energy it leaks into your team
and it leaks into the people that you
actually want to encourage and you want
them to do a good job and you want to
encourage them
and regularly
if i say to somebody what are you saying
to yourself when they say all these
horrible things i feel like would you
ever say it to your best friend would
you actually ever say oh you jerk oh i
can't believe you did totally screwed up
and they always would give their best
friend much more of a break and they
even would give their employees much
more of a break and the problem is when
they don't give themselves a break with
self-compassion it kind of leaks out and
it pollutes the environment
yeah so with so within so without right
it's very difficult to have one not
affect the other
where does i will be okay no matter what
that sentiment or that
feeling
come into this if it does
i think that
a lot of i'd say a lot of people a lot
of people but certainly a lot of people
in the workplace and my clients they
have this underlying fear and concern
what if this happens what if that
happens you know in large companies it
might be oh what if i get fired or what
if these layoffs affect me or whatever
and with a startup it might be oh what
if we fail what if we don't make it what
if we can't raise this funding
and there's just a lot of fear and worry
that shows up every day in the workplace
it's really very difficult to think
about so what i try to get them to
remember is this one thing is not
definitive of your entire life not only
that back to promise problems everywhere
you're always going to have problems so
if you can approach this particular
problem about maybe getting funding and
having trouble doing it or
maybe concerns about your job
realizing i will be okay no matter what
that helps you have some agency and some
empowerment in this matter whatever it
is
and so i always want to encourage them
to remember who are you really you have
a lot of resources you have a lot of
creativity you will figure your way out
of this problem just like you always
have because you will be okay no matter
what and i want people to take that on
take on the mantle of i will be okay no
matter what
you know that's been another one that
has taken well i shouldn't even put it
in past tense takes me a quite a bit of
reminder work to
remain present to it's part of the
reason why i spend so much more time in
and around nature now because the
further
my life is abstracted away from that the
more manufactured need and therefore
anxiety seems to pervade my day-to-day
existence yeah
yeah yeah it's so important it's really
really yeah
and notice how it's actually divorced
from circumstances i'll speak for myself
my life's changed quite a bit in the
past 20 years i know that your life has
changed too
the anxiety is kind of ever-present it
just changes what it attaches to
so you've got to find ways to counteract
the anxiety because the anxiety isn't
going away just because some
circumstance you think oh that thing
that i finally get will somehow cure my
anxiety
not really not i'm speaking for myself
not if you have some anxiety embedded
inside of you absolutely there's a piece
i can't recall the exact title but it's
from
school of life it's a really short
article called
and i'm paraphrasing i'll put the link
in the show notes but on finding
something to worry about i think it's
the title
and
again i'm paraphrasing but there's an
excellent line in there that really
struck me which is something along the
lines of
perhaps the thing you're so worried
about already happened
yeah alluding to the fact that we're so
informed by our experiences in childhood
and so on that
perhaps the thing that we are so so
worried is going to happen is actually
something that already happened and that
we can let go of
great peace along the baton a l a i n
space d e in the middle b o t d o n i
think is the spelling
all those things should help you find it
but we'll put it in the show notes so
let's talk about from startup to grownup
great title by the way
i'm really excited about this it's got
three sections managing you managing
them managing the business the appendix
contains what we mentioned earlier these
scripts for delicate situations which i
think is
in and of themselves makes the book
worth it in terms of picking up like
just to have a desk reference for
delicate situations i'm kind of a sucker
warm audience for scripts of any type so
i'm super excited about that and
i would love to just know
more about the journey of
creating the book and why you decided to
write a book because
writing books
turns out pretty hard takes a while so
you know
i don't actually know all the backstory
here so i would love for you to just
tell the story of how this book came to
be and why
so first of all in my case the book took
ten years to write
ten years plus six months the first ten
years were like oh i can't do it i'm not
good at this i can't do it so that was
extremely frustrating
i knew i had something to say and i
wanted to say it and also as i got more
and more involved with startups i really
saw oh there are these common things
that happen in startups i'll say like
where's your leadership team and they'll
say wait what's a leadership team or
i'll say well did you give them hey
you're like exactly you're right you're
right exactly
exactly or they'll say this person isn't
doing this job and i'll say well did you
hire for that job oh well we sort of
just like that person or whatever so i
see these things over and over and i i
really wanted to write a book
and i'll just tell you i was just kind
of in my own way
all my reasons i'm not sure if i can do
it
every time i sit down to write i go
blank i'm not sure how to structure it
all these things and then i wouldn't
necessarily devote the time to it
because it was very uncomfortable so i'd
rather do the things that were
comfortable for me so it took me quite a
long time
to get over that and it was actually
during the pandemic that i just thought
if you don't take this time to write
your book you're going to be so
disappointed in yourself
coming out of this pandemic what's going
to make you feel like i did not use my
time appropriately i did not use my time
well and the answer was that you didn't
write this book
so
i
talked to a number of friends i got a
lot of moral support i shed many tears
and i had anyway already had a contact
at a publisher
and so the wonderful kathy sweeney
and i talked together about this book
and we sort of finalized what i was
going to do
and then i don't know what happened but
everything just kind of changed like i
began to kind of tell my stories
and i was able to just talk about in
writing the experiences i'd had in
startups
and amazingly
the words i don't want to say they
flowed out of me there was plenty of
difficulty and butt in chair and
discipline around it
but i no longer back to self-talk i no
longer had this i can't do it in my head
i had instead i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna get this done what changed i have
to ask what changed what the hell
changed if you knew if you knew what
changed
what would it be
what would it be
okay the turning point i think
was my good friend and fellow coach and
one of the marshall goldsmith 100
coaches also michael bunysteiner
he was kind enough we were going to do
it in person when we were in london
together but we ended up doing it on
zoom he was kind enough to do this
process called immunity to change do you
know what that is i don't i read the
book i'm like i know that already i read
the book i know
but actually i'm doing it was very
helpful so it's i think his name is
robert keegan but
the process is
there's a reason
you say you want to do this thing you
say you want to change but you're not
changing
so it's like one foot is on the
accelerator
and one foot is on the brake
what's on the brake
and michael was kind enough to sit with
me as i talked about all my concerns and
issues turned out there were a lot of
them you say you want to write a book
yeah i want to write a book what's in
the way i don't know what if you did
know
i was able to reveal to myself with
michael's you know supportive help
what was in my way and all my
associations with how hard it was going
to be all my associations with what if i
it's really a lot of ego stuff like what
if it's not a good book what if nobody
likes it
i don't want to be that kind of person
who's always talking about my book
you know in my book i say
right
i also knew writing it was one thing and
then sort of the year after you know
when helping people
learn about it and promoting it was
another thing
and as we talked it was like i laid them
all out on the table
and i saw
really pretty physically pretty
physically all the things that were in
my way
what's interesting is that sometimes
just
surfacing the things that are in your
way
help you i'm not saying they don't go
away like oh magically
but
every time now resistance comes up
you're like oh yeah
i think it's going to be hard work or oh
yeah i don't want to be that person oh
yeah high high resistance i get it
and i was able to
overcome it in service of my bigger goal
which is
basically feeling proud
feeling proud of contributing this which
i think is going to be helpful to
founders
and also putting together my stories in
a way that makes me feel proud
and completing this project and this
work and again hoping it contributes to
people
that was going to make me proud and so i
saw the resistance for what it was and i
was able to move forward anyway
wow
kudos to to you and michael of course
taking you through the process
immunity to change is by robert keegan
k-e-g-a and subtitle how to overcome it
and unlock potential in yourself in your
organizations that's
that's also
easy to find
and
you know what your
with the exercise and your description
of it reminded me of
in terms of
identifying the resistance instead of a
well reminded me of two things remind me
of i think it's john dewey who said a
problem well stated is a problem have
solved something like that
but then it also reminded me
of another famous thinker and let's see
if i can see if i can do it justice like
nameless your fear be before banish it
you can that's yoda
um
you gotta name your fears
and right in applying the name often
time not all the time right this isn't
like you said this isn't intended to be
magical thinking but as soon as it is
kind of put in the light you're like oh
okay
now it's like this thing that is sitting
in front of me that i can look squirrely
in the eye as opposed to this like
bump in the middle of the night that is
preventing me from sleeping okay they
sort of get reduced they loom so large
inside of you and by the way there's
also some shame there like i can't tell
anybody
shame also kind of looms large and we're
able to get it on the table it kind of
neutralizes it and it whittles it down
to size it reduces it down to size
so can you elaborate on
the three sections in the book so from
start up to grown up do you have a
subtitle
yes it is grow your leadership while
growing your business mm-hmm
take it i dig it all right and then the
sections
managing you managing them managing the
business
how do those further break down
you know if i think about if i come in
and approach a startup and i approach a
founder my my first question is always
like what's going on around here and
what the hell is going on around here
yeah
so
i want to kind of get some perspective
in context it always comes down you know
founders always start with me with
something strong in the business or
we're not achieving our numbers or i'm
having these problems with my people
whatever they are but it always comes
down to
you
but it starts with you and that really
means
you beginning to think about your
self-awareness of 360 feedback that we
talked about but other self-awareness
getting to know your natural swing are
you a natural communicator do you tend
to clam up do you shut down in the face
of stress or do you get let's say overly
passionate and explosive with your team
so it's about you kind of doing an
inventory of your overly passionate
that's a great way to put it yeah
yeah and and so it's like coming to
terms with that but it's also about
recognizing back to what we talked about
in terms of self-talk it's about
realizing
that you as a founder are going to go
through a lot of ups and downs in this
journey which you might think is going
to take three years or five years but it
is not gonna take three years or five
years that is like a mythical story it's
gonna take a long time you're devoting a
lot of time to this
and how are you gonna take care of
yourself how are you gonna have the
right regimens of nutrition and sleeping
how are you going to transform your
self-talk would you have inevitable
impostor syndrome and like what's going
on so that's the first section it's
about you you you you
and then once you figure out you then
let's talk about them the employees so
it's about hiring it's about onboarding
it's about sadly firing which does
happen
it's about setting up the right systems
inside of your company to help you scale
you can no longer do everything at some
point once you grow so you've got to
find the ways and the tools and the
allies the other employees who come on
board to help you figure out what are
the structures are that are right that
how can help you scale one thing is
delegation many founders have a lot of
trouble delegating because it's like
their baby so it's about teaching you
how to give away the core elements of
your baby and trust that they can be
done
and then ultimately using all of that to
manage the business and then i want to
take a special i realize that this may
not be in the right section nonetheless
that's my book and the two pieces that
are also in the managing the company
section managing the business section
are about managing your board which
people always have questions about and
also managing the special relationship
known as your co-founder
[Laughter]
yes that marriage
including
prenups and checklist questions and i
just want to mention some of yours then
i'd love to hear others that you had but
three that jumped out to me because this
is
i have invested in a lot of companies
i've advised a bunch of companies and
not all marriages turn out to be
picture perfect you know riding off into
the sunset there are
lots of divorces and so some of the
questions that can help in advance so
that
you have some type of
agreement which could be called a
disagreement right because it's really
to contend with situations that are
problematic
what if one of us isn't scaling how will
we know and what we do about it and
these are your questions just to give
proper credit you know what will happen
if we get into a massive disagreement
that we can't resolve
how do we resolve it and what are the
kind of rules of engagement what does
success look like and how will we know
these are all so important because even
if the company does well let's take that
as a case the company is actually
developing some degree of traction
customers are paying
and
you have one founder who wants to get
out at a certain price a certain value
right
and then you have another who wants to
get out at 100 times that value or 10
times the value or two times that value
that's a big problem that could be a big
problem these are so so so important are
there any other
prenup checklist questions or other
questions that you think founders should
pay particular attention to and you have
many so to be fair they're quite
comprehensive but any that perhaps
people tend to neglect or omit
definitely what kind of company do you
want to build what's the culture of the
company what kinds of people do we want
to
hire
what are the important values we want to
have inside of this company because when
you don't come to terms with that one
co-founder is busy kind of hiring for
his group a certain kind of person
and then
the other co-founder is hiring for her
group a different kind of person so
ultimately you're almost like hiring two
companies so coming to terms with
actually the culture we're trying to
build is super important and i also
think that i want to go back to what you
said about
when do we want to as we say exit what
do we want to do with this company
it's amazing to me how people just don't
talk about that at the beginning of
their relationship the co-founder
relationship what they do is and i
understand this they're so excited about
building the company but they assume
they have the same music in their heads
together right they assume they're on
the same page with let's say building a
massive business or building a
manageable business building a lifestyle
business whatever it is and i just think
it's so important to have these
difficult conversations in advance
because i promise you they're going to
rear their ugly heads at some point and
so
having the conversation in advance may
not even resolve anything but at least
it brings up topics also getting used to
having sort of difficult conversations
or real talk conversations with your
co-founder i think is the key to the
whole thing whether or not you resolve
anything it's about getting in the habit
of bringing up uncomfortable topics
yeah for sure and an answer that isn't
an answer by the way is
we're going to build a 100-year company
yeah this is going to be huge we're
going to the giant publicly traded
companies okay no no but let's talk
about
in addition to that
what each person specifically hopes to
achieve financially and otherwise
because there will be opportunities even
if you're going to do that there are
going to be opportunities along the way
there will be seductions along the way
there will be offers along the way and
so it's really critical to have those
conversations
early what do you hope the book to do
what would a home run look like for you
i hope that the book inspires founders
to do more self-reflection for sure i
hope it helps founders prevent avoidable
mistakes that's what i really am and
also by the way new leaders there's a
lot of of material that's just kind of
if you're going from
individual contributor to manager to to
leader
there's a lot of the same journey you go
through so i'm hoping that it helps
people
solve those problems before they become
problems and give them language and
tools and insights to help them
on their journey basically i'd love to
coach everybody i hope it serves as like
a beacon for some people
i'm really excited about it and also
because i feel that
entrepreneurship however you define that
but this kind of
undertaking to create something from
nothing and things that often go along
with that let's just say really good
product sense
seeing a gap in the market some of those
things
come very very instinctively to people
yeah and they have good water feel they
just out of the box for whatever reason
they take to these types of things very
easily
and they can then on top of that build a
company but it's really a company in
name it's a legal entity of some type
but leadership in my experience
having observed god knows hundreds of
entrepreneurs at this point and having
been really involved with a lot of them
is not instinctive leadership and
management are not really instinctive
some aspects of leadership maybe but
really there's a point where you need
training even if you're a good swimmer
out of the box like you're not going to
end up in the olympics on accident
you're not going to end there deciding
what you want to do based on how you
feel every morning
and
having a playbook
that is informed by a lot of repetitions
and also a spectrum of exposure like
what you have in working with
you know everyone from
the kind of startup names that people
will recognize venmo etsy etc
but also the larger companies the dells
hitachi sony's googles and microsofts of
the world
there are
principles that work and yeah they're
not
all intuitive in fact a lot of them are
quite counter-intuitive
so i'm
excited to see
what
the book does
so congratulations
thank you tim i i do want to say and i i
hate to be like this because i said i
didn't want to be this kind of person
but i will say the first line of my book
is leadership is an unnatural act
okay it gets to you yeah yeah it gets to
your point of you know this stuff has to
be learned giving feedback has to be
learned even having sort of
uncomfortable conversations most of us
didn't grow up in a house where it was
like we all learned to do this and then
even if we did it just changes in the
professional context so i appreciate
what you just said and i appreciate your
kind words my pleasure i mean it
so i have to ask before we wrap up i'll
ask a few things
yeah
broadway shows and investor and broadway
shows i know nothing about broadway i've
been to a few shows really enjoyed it
i have
very narrow investment experience i
invest in highly speculative high-risk
early-stage tech companies and i know
how to do that on some level because
people have shared their rules are there
any resources or books for people who'd
want to learn more about the economics
and just the ecosystem of broadway and
what comes to mind for me for the
contemporary art world is a book i think
it's called the 12 million dollar
stuffed shark which was written by an
economist who's familiar with the
contemporary world there are a number of
other books like that for people who
want to kind of peer into the black box
and get a better understanding of how it
actually works
do you have any recommendations for
how one might learn more about that
well i think
meeting people is the best way to learn
but there is a book i'm gonna butcher
the names you're gonna have to find it
later
it's how to make a killing on broadway
or something like that yeah yeah
yeah and it's actually a very helpful
book there are a few other resources out
there that i have to think about
but mostly my best learning came from
sitting down with a number of
co-producers and just hearing about
their experiences
and i think like everything learning
from other people's mistakes is like the
best way
to learn about anything certainly about
the world of broadway one thing i just
want to say is that originally people
would send us a budget so here's the
capitalization of the show here's much
money we're going to raise here's the
budget and here's the break-even
analysis
and then as you you know luckily i am a
recovering cpa so
i can kind of dig into those numbers and
say
do your assumptions make sense here why
is this so expensive or why isn't this
expect when you see enough shows and you
do pattern recognition you say well you
should be allocating more money for this
what's going on it helps you ask better
questions
and i think that seeing a lot of deals
seeing a lot of packages is very helpful
yeah that makes sense to me that's true
certainly for the startup
as well the book i think maybe you can
confirm
is i want to be a producer subtitle how
to make a killing on broadway. or get
killed by john breglio
yes yes thanks tim yes all right found
it okay last few questions
and this one is sometimes a dead end but
i'll give it a shot and i'll take all
the blame if it is
if you could put any quote
message
word question anything at all
non-commercial on a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get something
out to
everyone in the united states for
instance
apolitical
what might you put on that billboard
okay
what comes to mind is
okay it's two-sided two-sided billboard
believe in yourself
is the first side
then act like it
is on the other side
act like you believe in yourself yeah
believe in yourself and then act like it
imagine that
and
people can find you
everywhere online do you have a
preferred
social that people should pay the most
attention to across twitter instagram
linkedin facebook and so on do you have
a
preferred handle somewhere
following me on linkedin is a good place
to find me
and certainly coming to my website
alyssacone.com
alyssacone.com a-l-i-s-a-c-o-h-n
dot-com the new book
is from startup to grown-up a guidebook
also including scripts i'm just going to
hit that again
for entrepreneurs on the leadership
journey from founder and ceo
super excited about that is there
anything else you would like to
say any closing comments anything you'd
like to add before we wrap up for today
tim two things one is thank you for
having me today it's been really great
to catch up with you and to talk to you
in this conversation i really appreciate
it
and the second thing is just i want to
say thank you for all the work you've
done over the years for
sharing certainly world-class practices
and tactics and also for your recent
i think really courageous work and
revelations about your trauma from
childhood and also about your exposing
this new world of psychedelic science i
know it's been helpful to a lot of
people and i just really want you to
know what a difference it's made
thank you alyssa i really appreciate
that and it's so nice to reconnect and
we have much more to catch up on which
we'll do
offline so uh that's to be continued but
this has been so much fun i'm really
excited for you and the new book
and for the ongoing career of k bell for
those who don't know that's her
stage name for her rap as in kettlebell
and
i'm really looking forward to watching
this all unfold with this new chapter
pun intended
with from startup to grown-up so thank
you for taking the time today
and for everybody listening
believe in yourself and then act like
you believe in yourself
two-sided billboard
and thank you for tuning in you can find
show notes links to everything we have
discussed at tim.blog
podcast and until next time thanks for
listening
hi everyone
tim asked me to give you guys a few
scripts so i'm going to share with you
some of the ones the leaders i coach
find most useful
the founders and leaders i work with
they find scripts super helpful when i
walk them through how i would say
something as we're talking they scribble
it down furiously and they ask me to
repeat it and it made me realize that
people struggle with the actual words to
say so i began to develop scripts that
people can use to handle delicate
situations difficult conversations
difficult situations
now remember all of these scripts are
just guides you're going to have to
tailor them to your own situation but
they should give you a running start
i'm going to give you a selection of
scripts here
i created this set just for tim's
listeners they're not in my book or on
my website there are a few categories
for you based on what my clients have
found the most helpful
first i'm going to share a set of five
feedback scripts that lead up to firing
someone since this is naturally a very
difficult conversation and you need help
for that
next i'll give you a script to help you
get feedback in your job so you can get
promoted
then a few scripts about how to have
great one-on-ones including how to use
your one-on-one to give career coaching
to your employees
followed by how to tell someone you're
bringing a new leader in to manage them
the last ones will be but my favorite
topic networking and i'll give you some
easy ways for you to network including a
script you can use to reach out to
someone you've been out of touch with
for a long time
now when i ask people what's the most
common script they wish they could have
the number one answer by far is how to
fire someone which i can totally
understand since firing someone sucks
but you have to do it sometimes that's
your job sometimes as a manager
so i'm going to give you five feedback
scripts here ending with how to fire
someone
and these are for founders they're
really for any leader or manager or for
anybody who is responsible for hiring
people
working with them to help them to get
their jobs right doing coaching and
feedback with them and then ultimately
again if the time comes firing them if
they have to
the one i'm going to start with is
positive feedback script that may
surprise you but this is the script that
nobody asks for but almost every manager
needs
i'm starting with positive feedback
because i think that people
underestimate how really important it is
to give your people positive feedback on
a regular basis we always talk about
feedback as if it's negative but
actually many managers have to learn the
skill of making sure that they praise
their people they give them positive
feedback on a regular basis that helps
motivate your employees it helps them be
more confident and take more risks and
ultimately it builds up goodwill between
you and your employees so that you can
deliver a difficult message in the
future if you need to because they
already have the experience of being
complimented by you and being
appreciated by you so they know you're
on their side
now i think what gets in the way for
managers is
first of all they're not thinking about
it and second of all it can actually be
a little uncomfortable almost a little
embarrassing for some people to give
positive feedback especially if they
didn't grow up with their own positive
feedback from other people
it's like the workplace version of i
love you so having a script will help
you and practice will help you too
so first of all what you need to do is
find something to complement it doesn't
have to be the nobel prize of activities
that they do to make you realize that
you can complement them did they do a
good job planning a meeting did they do
a solid draft of a deck for you are they
doing a great job getting up to speed on
something it can really be anything that
you're really proactively noticing to
give them positive feedback so next is
be specific now here are some examples
here are some specific scripts that you
can take to just give quick positive
feedback
bill
that spreadsheet you gave me was so
clear and well formatted well done
andrea
i know that your counterpart in
marketing can sometimes be overly
emotional i really appreciate that you
go the extra mile to maintain a
productive relationship with him
chris
i'm so impressed with how you handled
yourself in that board meeting your
presentation was excellent really well
structured and you de-escalated a tense
moment which could have derailed us
now there's another spin on this which
is encouraging even when someone is
struggling
jennifer
i know you're behind on that project i
just want to make sure you're okay
i see how hard you're working and i know
some issues came up that none of us
anticipated it's super frustrating but i
appreciate your hanging in there and i
know you'll solve the issues and get it
behind you
it's really nice when you express
confidence in someone's ability to solve
problems even when something's going
wrong
now if you are like many leaders and
managers you know you need to give more
positive feedback i would suggest you
literally put it on your calendar or
make a spreadsheet to remind you to do
this
because it's important for you to
integrate that into your day-to-day and
week-to-week and i promise it'll make a
massive difference to your employees and
it'll increase their productivity and
loyalty
now very often it's great for you to
give positive feedback and just leave it
right there have them have the
experience of just being praised
then sometimes it's important to take
the positive feedback and use it as a
springboard to help them build a new
skill or think about something
differently so i'm calling this one
developmental feedback this is not
constructive criticism that will come
later but when you think about
development feedback it has to do with
somebody understanding what they're
doing well and then what they can build
on top of it to be even better most
employees actually think this is good
news they understand they're doing well
and good employees always want to know
how to improve so when you set it up
with positivity and then also be
specific
you can create that bridge to
you're doing great and then do more of
this so now here's the script you can
use and there are two examples
one is for a more junior employee
chris i love how you jump into all your
projects so enthusiastically and move so
fast in getting your work done and your
cheerful attitude towards everything is
so refreshing and it's even infectious
i'd love you to advance your game in
this one area when you complete a
project rather than just send it off
pause for a minute and think about how
to make sure it's really finished for
example sometimes when you send me a
spreadsheet there are some mistakes that
i bet you would catch if you looked it
over
or when you send emails i think they'd
have more impact if you proofread them
could i ask you to give your finished
products a second look to try to catch
errors before you send them off let's
check in about this in a few weeks and
see how it's going
here's a script for a manager someone a
little more senior
tammy you're doing a great job managing
your team they love you and your whole
group is getting more productive every
month i love the systems you implemented
now that you've gotten your arms around
your team
i'd like you to prioritize building
relationships and coordinating with your
peers
we need to be synced up at the
leadership level and i have the
impression that not everybody knows what
your team is doing so can i ask you to
make sure you prioritize getting to know
your peers better and sharing your goals
with them and getting them to share
theirs with you
let's touch base next month to see how
it's going what help do you need from me
notice that the whole tone of this is
positive it's clear that you appreciate
your employee it's clear that you see
what they're doing well and it's clear
the specific thing you're asking them to
change or to fine-tune and there's even
a bit of a follow-up plan with a date
that is perfect and the hope is that
they're going to take that and run with
it and continue to improve
if they don't take it and run with it
and continue to improve
you then want to have the next
conversation which is the difficult
feedback conversation this actually is
constructive criticism the issue here is
that often you've seen the same problems
over and over with your executive or
employee and they need to make changes
and they haven't made these changes
that's when you really need to address
them in a more specific and maybe
intensive way
here's a script for you to do that
matthew in the past month you've made
two major decisions that touch the
product team and the marketing team
without consulting them or even letting
them know
you've missed the opportunity to get
their feedback which would be valuable
and their input which is essential to
the success of our project
and now i'm concerned that because they
haven't been in the loop they're not
going to co-own the process with you so
it's going to be much harder for us to
finish this project
we've talked about this before and you
told me that you'd make sure to get
people's input before you made decisions
i need you to fix this one problem by
going and talking to these folks right
now and then even more critically i need
you to operate differently from now on
you're not going to be successful and we
won't be successful as a business if you
don't collaborate a lot more closely
i'd love to hear back from you by the
end of the week about your plan to solve
this once and for all i'm here to help
you if you need me and i'm more than
happy to talk through your plan but i
need you to take ownership of this issue
and fix it
here you've communicated to them the
seriousness of the issue the specific
thing you want them to go and fix
and the timeline that you want to hear
back from them it's not just going to
like fall off the radar that you've
actually agreed on a time frame they're
going to come back and give you a plan
that's important to make forward motion
my suggestion to you is that you role
play this i know you don't want to role
play it nobody wants to role play but i
really encourage you to do that because
first of all it's going to help you get
your tone neutral and that's going to
possibly reduce defensiveness and set up
actually a good dialogue after this
conversation which is important
and the second is that when you get a
little nervous it's hard to have your
mouth around the words and when you role
play it it forces you to say the words
out loud
now let's assume that you've had a
couple of these conversations and things
have not improved that is disappointing
but we have to get to the conversation
before the firing conversation you never
want people to be surprised when they
get fired and you also want to tell
yourself i did everything i could to
help this person make changes and i
communicated to this person and the
person should not be surprised so
that's why it's important just for you
and your own sanity and also to give
them a chance to make sure that you have
the conversation before the fireman
conversation again i really encourage
you to role play this it's hard to land
but it's super important also they're
going to be upset this is an upsetting
conversation so be humane and be
compassionate but also be clear
the issue might be performance or it
might be leadership or cultural
qualities i'm going to give you two
scripts
i'll start with performance
camellia we need to have a serious
conversation you and your team have
consistently not met your goals or even
come close and as a result we've had to
move the new product launch twice at the
last minute
i know things come up but your job is to
anticipate what those things are
manage your team to deal with them and
work with your peers to coordinate all
of it and i don't see you doing that
what i need you to do is immediately
debrief with your team and your peers
pull together a launch schedule that
will meet our business goals and then
make that date
if you can't do that within the next two
months i'm sorry to tell you i'm going
to have to find a new leader to take
your role and we're going to have to
part ways
i'm telling you this because i want you
to know where i stand on this and i want
you to take it seriously
if there's anything you need for me to
help you improve let me know
i want to hear back from you by the end
of the week about how you're approaching
this
and here's your second version related
to leadership and culture
matthew we need to have a serious
conversation
we've talked in the past about my
concerns about you're making unilateral
decisions about areas that affect other
areas of the business
collaboration and transparency are super
important values here and if you keep
making decisions in a vacuum you aren't
being collaborative or transparent
you're also not getting good ideas from
others you're surprising people and
you're not getting buy-in from the
people that you need
you're also making people feel dismissed
it's not a sustainable way to work
i need you to know that if you can't fix
this issue we're going to have to part
ways
i'm telling you this because i want you
to know where i stand and i want you to
take it seriously i need you to fix this
immediately by mending fences with your
peers and employees and taking into
account their input before key decisions
if there's anything you need for me to
help you let me know i want to hear back
from you by the end of the week about
how you're approaching this and i need
to see improvement within 30 days
now this is definitely one you're going
to want to role play and remember to
stay even keeled and be ready for a
discussion after this i can't give you a
script for an unscripted dialogue that's
going to take place after you land this
one
so in your role play think through how
your employee might respond and what you
might say during the discussion that
will follow when you prepare for what
they say in response and practice
getting your mouth around the words of
the script it will make you feel much
more confident and then you can stay
present and listening and also continue
to reiterate your intention clearly
which is that this is a serious problem
and your employee has to fix it
you've tried to work with them to help
them improve you've told them in no
uncertain terms what you need them to do
and they haven't done it and now it is
time to have the conversation in which
you fire them
so even though you've already discussed
it with them even though you've given
them plenty of signals they still may be
surprised because they didn't really
think you were going to fire them
we all have a high capacity to deceive
ourselves when we want to make sure you
use decisive language so there's no
question and that there's no sort of
wiggling around it and again be humane
it sucks for you but it's actually worse
for them
so before you fire someone think about
your plan
tell your board or whoever your boss is
that you're going to fire this person
and why hopefully you've already given
them a heads up about the issue tell
your hr person and help them help make
sure you have a transition plan ready
and you have to think about the things
like severance and termination agreement
already lined up
and then after you do this you tell the
person's peers
the person's direct reports than the
rest of the company
so remember to be compassionate and also
clear
and here is the script to fire somebody
camellia when we talked about six weeks
ago i told you i needed you to get your
arms around the issues with your team
and work with them and your peers to get
the launch back on track to meet our
business goals
so far you still don't have a realistic
date your team is not clear on what's
going on and neither are your peers
it's time to part ways i know that's
hard to hear but that's my decision
let me tell you with the transition plan
and the severance plan
so of course after that camellia may
want more of an explanation
and she may protest
but you know that you've had a whole
bunch of feedback conversations with her
and that she couldn't be completely
surprised you also know that
specifically you had the conversation
before the firing conversation so
although this may still be difficult
you've gotten your words out you've been
clear on what's going to happen and now
it's just the details of sorting all
that out so i hope that was helpful all
the conversations leading up to having
the firing conversation and then
ultimately the firing conversation
let's move away from that shall we and
move on to some different topics
i'm actually now going to put you on the
other side of the feedback conversation
how you can get more feedback maybe
you're not getting promoted but nobody's
telling you why it's actually hard to
get feedback at work
so i'm going to give you a sense a
script for how you can get more feedback
from your manager to help you get
promoted but before you do this do some
prep work first
look around your company what kinds of
people are getting promoted what
characteristics do they have what sets
them apart so i would encourage you to
do like an anthropological study so you
begin to get a sense of what's valued
around your company and then you can
adapt your own behavior to what's valued
now once you've done that you can
definitely and you should definitely go
and ask your manager for feedback
the reason you're not getting feedback
is that people don't enjoy giving
feedback
uh they don't know how to
they're squeamish
they also don't know how you're going to
react so you might have to insist on
this
and that way you'll get useful feedback
from your manager
here's a script you can use
suzanne i've been thinking about my
career
as you know i want to be able to have
more impact and i want to progress in my
career so it's important to me to know
if i'm on track on getting promoted
now i've seen a few of my peers get
promotions lately
and i'd love to talk to you about my
performance and what it'll take for me
to get to the next step
your manager might say you're doing
great keep doing what you're doing and
then you can say i appreciate that
that's really nice to hear
but i've realized that i need more
guidance to help me get where i'm going
do you have any suggestions for me
asking for suggestions can be easier for
them to respond to than feedback then
she might say i don't see you being
proactive
or you need to show up more as a leader
and that's annoying because what the
heck does that mean
but don't say that
say thank you
because you want them to give your
feedback regularly
and you got to reward that behavior when
you actually rest something out of your
bosses so here's what you can say in
response to that thank you for sharing
that i appreciate it
would you mind if we spent a few minutes
talking about what it would look like if
i was showing up more as a leader
are there behaviors you can point me to
then you might find out that you may
seem dismissive of your peers if they
can't keep up which is not good
or
you might find out that you don't
proactively coach more junior employees
so you're not showing up as a leader now
you may not agree with that but at least
now you know what's in your boss's
mind's eye
you've got to listen to what she says
ask questions in a neutral tone of voice
and overall make it a positive
experience for whoever's giving you this
feedback
that way they'll give you more feedback
and then you'll have a better sense of
how you're showing up and what you need
to do to get that promotion
at the end of the conversation ask if
you can check in in about a month and
then make sure you do that so if you'll
be consistent and be pleasant to deal
with you're much more likely to get the
feedback that you need to get ahead
now let's go back to you and your role
as a leader and we can talk about
one-on-ones
one-on-ones are a foundation of how you
can build the right relationship with
your employees and also it's a way for
you to hear what's going on with them
so here's a script you can use to either
set or reset expectations for your
employees if this is the first time
you're doing one-on-ones you can set the
expectations but if you've been doing
them for a while a different way then
you can use this conversation and you
can just adapt it to reset the
expectations
donnie i wanted to give you a sense of
how i view one-on-ones and also to get
your take
i think of our one-on-ones as mostly
your meeting whatever you want to bring
up is definitely on point let's not just
do status updates if you have questions
about what's going on the company if you
have a great idea you want to share or
if there's something you want my advice
on
bring them up here
we can also talk about your career path
i'm sure i'll have things on my mind and
let's check in every once in a while to
make sure they're working for both of us
okay
then when you do your one-on-ones ask
your employee to prepare by thinking
about the topics that they'd like to
discuss now they may not do this very
well at first but that's okay they'll
learn
if you stick with it you'll both get the
hang of this and you'll adapt your
one-on-ones to be more satisfying for
both of you
here are some questions you can ask your
employees so that you can have a deeper
conversation about work in your
one-on-one
what do you like best and what do you
dislike the most about your job
where do you see yourself going your
career and how can i help you get there
do you know where we're headed big
picture as a company and you have any
questions about it
do you know what your top priorities are
are you having any problems working
things out with any co-worker and do you
need my help
what suggestions do you have for me
these are great questions to start you
off
remember that you don't have to solve
all of their problems in fact a really
good role for you of this one-on-one is
for you to coach them to help them
solve their own problems also it's just
get a handle on what's going on with
your employees and also certainly if
they have specific asks of you this is a
good moment for them to tell you so that
you can help them in the way that they
want help you can also use your
one-on-one for career coaching and i
absolutely encourage you to do this
so a few times a year make sure your
employee knows this in advance that
you're going to do this career coaching
remember that your job is to coach and
support not to do all the work for them
you can tell them straight up
that you think it's a good idea to do
career coaching now and again and here's
a script that you can use to introduce
this topic
i think it's a good idea to sit down
regularly and talk about your career
development
let's do that a few times a year so i
know what you want to do and i can help
you achieve those goals
first of all you just get a ton of
points as a manager
just even bringing that up because most
employees do not have the experience of
having their managers come and
proactively talk about their careers
now again all you have to do is ask them
questions and then be supportive and
help them problem solve
to get where they're going here are some
questions you can ask
do you have a sense of where you'd like
to go in your career in the next few
steps
by the way it's okay if they don't but i
would encourage you to keep asking them
to help make sure they're pointed in the
right direction
what parts of your job right now do you
like the most and what do you like the
least
what kinds of training or experiences
will help you move in the direction
you're interested in
if you don't know how should we find out
is there anyone inside or outside the
company you think you could learn a lot
from and want to spend more time with
what would you specifically like to
commit to so that you can make sure that
you're moving forward on your career
growth and how can i help you
then you can close this discussion by
saying
i'm here to help you with your career
growth and of course to help you do a
great job at your job if you ever want
to discuss these topics with me just
come to me you don't have to wait until
i initiate them if you ever think we
need to discuss this more please just
tell me don't wait for me to figure it
out for myself so that puts the
responsibility on your employee not just
you the manager so it's really a joint
responsibility to have these
conversations but your employee can feel
free to take ownership
here's another one on one that's not so
fun but it's really important to be able
to tell employees this
how to tell someone you're bringing in a
manager on top of them
we often call it layering because it's
about putting a layer of management on
top of your employees it's actually very
common in the startup world because what
happens is the company's successful
which is great and what that means is
you need to bring in more seasoned
executives to help
manage the company at the new scale so
it's great news but employees really
don't like this they see it as unfair
because they've been there for so long
and they're not getting the opportunity
and they might even see it as a demotion
it's not a demotion
it's actually again good news not bad
news but not to them so you have to help
them understand it and you have to be
transparent about it
so here's a script to address it
elena i'm making some changes and i want
to discuss them with you you've done a
tremendous job bringing your department
to where it is now
what you've accomplished has been
amazing and we literally could not have
gotten where we are without you
because of your hard work and everybody
else's hard work we're hitting our
milestones and we're growing and that's
awesome
to help us get to the next level i'm
going to be bringing in some seasoned
leaders who have scaled companies like
ours before
they'll have the experience and the
context to bring us to the next level
what that means for you is that i'll be
bringing an executive in to run your
department and you'll report to this new
person
i want you to know i'll be looking for
the right leader who'll also mentor you
and help build your skills and your
career so that you can continue to grow
if you want to talk about this i'm happy
to discuss it i want you to be happy but
i also want you to know this is what
i've decided to do
now as i said many employees are not
going to like this but it's one of the
tough decisions that you have to make as
a ceo or as any leader
and in fact i'm sure it's the right
decision because you're looking at the
business you're assessing what the
business needs and you're making
decisions based on what the business
needs
some employees might leave now most will
stay and if you tell them straight up
your plan they'll appreciate that you're
being honest
it is definitely important to bring in a
great leader and if people see they can
learn a lot from the new executive
that will reinforce your decision and
they'll ultimately be happy with their
role and the overall success of the
company
i'm going to end this with one of my
favorite topics networking i was
inspired a long time ago by a book
called dig your well before your thirsty
by harvey mckay
and more recently by the book super
connect by richard kosh and greg
lockwood
the point of these books is to
understand the power of building and
nourishing a network and doing this
before you actually need anything
your network is important because
through your network you can get the
best job opportunities the best advice
and frankly it's just fun to have
interesting people in your life and you
get them through your network
keep in touch with your network and give
first when you think about how you can
add value to the people around you you
build up a tribe and they'll be willing
to help you when you need it
so i'm going to give you a few super
simple networking scripts and also
suggestions the first suggestion is to
keep in touch with your old friends and
colleagues now that can be hard to do
especially when we're all busy so the
best way to handle this is to keep a
spreadsheet or a list of people who are
important to you personally and
professionally you can list out 10
people or you can list out 50 people or
100 whatever feels manageable for you
and then regularly scan your environment
for opportunities to be in touch with
them
so an example is you might see on
linkedin that one of your contacts got
promoted or just wrote a book or changed
jobs or got quoted in some newspaper or
whatever
this doesn't have to be their biggest
achievement ever you could just write a
quick note of congratulations
in my network i recently read that one
of the broadway producers that i know
got named to a prestigious committee
so i sent him a note and i said hi brian
i just saw that you got named to the xyz
committee congratulations
they're lucky to have you i hope
everything else in your world is also
going great that's it it took 20 seconds
he wrote back to me in 30 minutes and he
was so happy to hear from me because
people love being congratulated and
acknowledged for an honor
so be on the lookout for that
you might also see an article or a book
that would interest them or come across
a memory of some sort i have a former
client who's embarking on a sabbatical
and i recently saw an article about
things to do on your sabbatical
i sent her a quick email hi kayla i saw
this article and i thought it might help
you as you start your sabbatical
let me know if you like to brainstorm
how to get the most out of your downtime
and also enjoy it hope it's starting off
great again 20 seconds super easy
offering to help is a great way to
cultivate your network
as you communicate with people or see
them on social media you'll get a sense
of what's going on with them maybe
they're moving and you might know people
in their new city
maybe their kid is looking for an
internship and you know of a good
program for her
you can just send a quick note offering
to help
i'll give you an example
sam the son of a friend of mine was
trying to transition out of being a
lawyer and looking for a job in the
startup world i happen to know the
founder of a startup who was building a
legal platform
it was very quick and very simple to
write her a note that said
hi mandy looks like your company is
doing great i know someone who's trying
to transition from being a lawyer into
the startup world he's super smart
proactive and can juggle multiple balls
and obviously he knows all about the
legal profession do you want an intro
she said yes i connected them and then
she hired him and they both thanked me
it felt great
that's a moment that reminds me how
fruitful networking is and how
satisfying it is
remember to dig your well before you're
thirsty and stay in touch with key
people but if you do need a favor from
someone you haven't talked to in a while
just reach out be warm and be direct
don't pretend that you were just
thinking about them
they're going to find out that you
actually need something so just be
honest and up front and give them an out
to say no
here's an email you can write to someone
you know whom you've lost touch with
hi brian i hope you've been well
i saw on linkedin that you moved to
denver i'm sure it's wonderful for you
to be there since i know you always love
to ski
i'm sorry we've lost touch over the
years i'd love to get reconnected anyway
and hear how you're doing
the reason though that i'm reaching out
right now is that i have a specific ask
i'm looking for a new job in marketing
and your company is on my dream list i'm
wondering if you'd consider connecting
me to some of the folks in your
marketing department not to ask them for
a job but just to begin to get to know
some people there if it's not a good
time i totally understand and no worries
at all either way it would be great to
get in touch then send it
and don't think about it they'll either
write back or they won't either way let
it inspire you to stay in touch with
your network consistently
so that's it
i hope that you find this material as
helpful as my clients do and i
absolutely hope that you take one or two
things away from this scripps master
class and practice them so that you can
gain real dexterity and real mastery
over the way you can handle sensitive
topics and sensitive conversations and
be able to say the right thing to the
right people at the right time feel free
to reach out to me through my website
alyssacone.com
and i'd love to hear how you use this
material and what the difference it made
for you
thank you
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every friday that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and five
bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that i've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include favorite articles
that i've read and that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four hour
workweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up i
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by all
forms if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which i've been using
since 2017. i have two of them upstairs
from where i'm sitting at this moment
and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so i'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all formed furniture i've
got two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional couch i'll come back
to that you can pick your fabric they're
all spill stained and scratch resistant
the soap color the color of the legs so
the size the shape to make sure it's
perfect for you and your home also all
form arrives in just three to seven days
and you can assemble it all yourself in
a few minutes no tools needed i was
quite astonished by how modular and easy
these things fit together kind of like
lego pieces they've got arm chairs love
seats all the way up to an 8c sectional
so there's something for everyone you
can also start small and kind of build
on top of it if you want to get a
smaller couch and then build out on it
which is actually in a way what i did
because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman in a matter of about 60 seconds
it's pretty rough so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural light finish which is
their lightest color and i dig it and
i've been using these things hours and
hours and hours every single day so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever so check it out take a
look they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical
and it actually worked it worked much
better than i could have imagined and
i'm very very happy so to find your
perfect sofa check out allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com make sure you to use the
code tim at checkout that's allforum.com
tim and use code tim at checkout
this episode is brought to you by kettle
and fire do you love me my kettle and
fire i believe i first heard about
kettle and fire when it was originally
recommended to me by
one of your favorites fan favorite
podcast guest and ketogenesis expert
among many other things dr dominic de
agostino so what is kettle on fire
kettle and fire offers premium bone
broth made with bones from 100 grass-fed
and grass-finished cows and organic
free-range chickens they can buy bones
with organic herbs and vegetables and
filtered water and steel kettles
then the mixture is slow simmered for 14
plus hours at 130 degrees fahrenheit to
ensure that as many nutrients collagen
and amino acids as possible are able to
soak into the broth
and all that goodness is fantastic for
supporting your gut health immune system
weight loss your fasting regimen
whatever it might be and they make it
extremely convenient just heat and eat
five minutes on the stovetop or one
minute in the microwave it's great as a
snack you can also sip it straight out
of a mug or honestly sometimes i just
sip it right out of the box you can also
add it as a flavor to recipes and they
sent me some eye popping stats it's
pretty amazing 24
million plus cartons sold 25 000 plus
five star reviews on amazon on their own
website two years shelf life and zero
preservatives added flavors antibiotics
hormones or colorings and all of their
broths are paleo keto friendly and bowl
30 approved they're also my neighbors
here in austin texas and i'm happy to
support a local company so
check them out you can save 25 off of
your order by going to kettleandfire.com
tim that's spelled out k-e-t-t-l-e
a-n-d-f-i-r-e fire.com tim using code
tim at checkout one more time that's
kettleandfire.com
tim and code tim at checkout
[Applause]
you